[Musique]
bonjour à tous édition spéciale
poursuivre aujourd'hui la nouvelle
lecture au sénat du budget de la
sécurité sociale sans plus attendre
on se dirigeait à l'hémicycle pour
suivre cette séance au chapitre premier
à l'article 24 à nous avons l'amendement
200 de madame cohen mon ami de madame
bravo madame hillman oui chers collègues
cet amendement l'article en question
prévoit une trajectoire pluriannuelle du
financement pour les établissements de
santé
cette mesure est bienvenu car les
établissements réclament depuis
longtemps de la visibilité et de la
lisibilité mais on s'interroge sur la
pertinence de la vision pluriannuelle
sur augmentation de budget si c'est pour
faire comme c'est le cas à annoncer aux
hôpitaux qu'ils auront moins de moyens
pour les quatre prochaines années
ils vont effectivement pouvoir se
projeter dans la déprime et la baisse de
la baisse de la qualité des soins
c'est pour ça que nous proposons la
suppression de l'article 24 à merci
monsieur le rapporteur de présidence
c'est la commission a donné un avis
défavorable à cet amendement de
suppression
parce que cet article répond à des
attentes fortes des acteurs hospitaliers
de disposer d'une plus grande visibilité
sur leurs ressources
le système actuel crée une incertitude
permanente qui obère les capacités des
établissements décidé de le choix à
moyen terme comme en matière
d'investissements pour l'innovation donc
le protocole prévu par cet article
n'empiétera pas sur les points les
prérogatives du parlement à travers le
vote annuel de l'ondam qui restera un
acte bien sûr décisionnel donc avis
défavorable merci madame istres
défavorables aussi donc je me revois à
l'amande temps avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
160 qui le défend oui monsieur hurel
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre que l'aic je présente cet
amendement présenté en première
signataire par jasmin et tout le groupe
socialiste il s'agit de poser le
principe il s'agit de compléter
l'article l'animé à 4 cet article 24 1
par pour permettre une évaluation à la
fin de chaque photo call à la fin de
leur période d'application avec
accompagné s'il le faut de
préconisations cet amendement pose le
principe que sur une base contractuelle
uniquement d'un financement pluriannuel
les établissements de santé publics et
privés afin d'assurer une stabilité de
leurs ressources ou plusieurs années
cette garantie s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un protocole signé entre l'état et les
représentants de ces établissements dont
le suivi et l'application sont dévolues
aux comités économiques de
l'hospitalisation publique et privée
le risque est que cette garantie ne soit
qu'une garantie de moyens insuffisants
c'est pourquoi l'objectif de cet
amendement vise à s'assurer qu'à la fin
de sa période applications comme je le
disais une évaluation du protocole soit
réalisée par ce comité avec le passage
en des préconisations pour un nouveau
protocole
merci merci monsieur à porter la
commission a décidé de s'en remettre à
la sagesse du sénat parce que le texte
prévoit déjà confié au comité économique
de l'hospitalisation le suivi et
l'application du protocole sur la
trajectoire pluriannuelle de ressources
et la commission ne voit pas
d'inconvénient expliciter le fait qu il
en assurera également l'évaluation mais
on a dit sagesse 1 à ministre mais
monsieur le président merci de l'article
prévoit déjà en effet que le comité est
chargé du suivi et de l'application du
protocole donc de ce fait votre
amendement est satisfait donc sereine
demande de retrait selon un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur lurel il est maintenu il
est maintenue dont je le mets euros avec
un avis de sagesse de la commission un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté je me revois l'article 24 ha
qui est pour
pardon pardon excusez moi une
explication de vote
oui très rapidement pour dire nous
voterons cet article il correspond en
effet une préconisation
enfin en partie à une préconisation du
rapport que nous avons nous avons fait
avec rené paul savary où nous souhaitons
justement un ondam pluriannuel une plus
grande visibilité par rapport aux
différents acteurs
donc c'est partiellement ce qui est fait
dans cet article est encore du chemin à
parcourir mais nous voterons cet article
merci cher que l'iphone à millau teint
le groupe rds votre à cet article car en
faisant le tour des hôpitaux que ce soit
les hôpitaux privés privé les espy coup
les hôpitaux publics
c'était une demande forte en fait des
établissements hospitaliers qui sont
satisfaits en fait de cette visibilité
pluriannuelle du financement merci donc
je mets ce jeu mais l'on voit l'article
24 à qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté l'article à
l'article 24 l'amendement 201 pendant la
prise de parole de même boulet pardon
oui messieurs président même madame la
ministre les au moment où on parle de
des hôpitaux
vous parlez des hôpitaux de proximité
surtout des groupement hospitalier
territoriaux parce qu'il se passe au
niveau des groupements hospitalier
territoriaux ce qui se passe dans les
intercommunalités quand vous avez une
grosse commune et des communes rurales
autour
quand vous avez un groupement
hospitalier territorial et un chu vous
avez des disparités terrible entre eux
entre les structures et j'ai visité
cette semaine l'hôpital d'argentan on
racontait notamment que ce groupe
hospitalier territorial contraignez cet
hôpital de proximité à être soumis aux
règles d'appels d'offres je vous donne
l'exemple
très simple d'un achat de pain qui se
faisait localement qui maintenant doit
se faire dans le cadre d'un appel
d'offres donc le pain est livré à
argentan depuis evreux il coûte plus
cher
il arrive congelés donc c'est tout à
fait contraire à tout le développement
durable le travail de proximité etc et
donc l'intérêt de ces groupement
hospitalier territoriaux seraient dans
le cadre de la négociation avec les
hôpitaux de proximité d'obtenir une
charte
le ministre qu'il puisse y avoir comme
dans les intercommunalités
une charte qui lie les établissements de
façon à avoir un processus équilibré à
la fois dans les plannings à la fois
dans les approvisionnements et
éventuellement de pouvoir déroger aux
règles des appels d'offres et donc je
crois que dans le cadre du travail qui
est en train d'être faits sur ces
groupes hospitaliers et territoriaux
pardon à ils sont peut-être pas très
débrouillard c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'exprime en leur nom en
tous les cas ils peuvent pas dérogé à ce
genre de choses et donc moi je voulais
madame madame la ministre vous demander
toute votre attention pour que dans le
cadre des négociations à venir sur ces
groupement hospitalier on puisse
éventuellement obtenir ces chartes et
donc faire très attention et privilégier
ces hôpitaux de proximité
merci chers collègues d'autres passions
à l'amendement 201 malagré sommes nous
proposons par cet amendement de
supprimer cet article qui actent dans
son versant budgétaire la mort des
hôpitaux de proximité
en effet depuis trente ans beaucoup
d'hôpitaux de proximité aux disparus et
votre loi d'organisation et de
transformation du système de santé
débattu avant l'été contre laquelle
notre groupe s'est battu fini d'achever
ce qui reste ce plfss confirme encore
plus nos craintes puisque le financement
des hôpitaux de proximité qui prévoit
est tout bonnement à propre à maintenir
leur état de fonctionnement vous pouvez
continuer à affirmer le contraire
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
mais lors de notre tour de france de
plus de 160 hôpitaux nous avons pu voir
la manière dont vous transformer des
établissements existants
en hôpitaux de proximité en les
réduisant à de véritables coquilles
vides
privés de leurs services essentiels vous
déterminez vous détournez l'expression
d'hôpitaux de proximité car vous savez
que les françaises et les français y
sont attachés
tout comme de nombreux élus avec mon
groupe et le groupe gère gdr à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons déposé
une proposition de loi visant à
redéfinir les hôpitaux de proximité
comme étant des établissements dotés
d'un service d'urgence d'une maternité
de niveau 1 et 2 services de médecine et
de chirurgie dotés de services de soins
de suite et de structures pour les
personnes âgées en lien avec un réseau
de centres de santé et la psychiatrie de
secteur
si vous voulez répondre de manière
efficace aux revendications des
personnels des hôpitaux et des patientes
et patients
je vous suggère de prendre au sérieux
cette proposition de loi qui reprend de
manière exhaustive toutes les mesures
attendues attendus par ces derniers pour
ce faire il est clair que l'ondam doit
être réévalué à 4,5 pour cent voire 5 %
par an pour investir dans la rénovation
des hôpitaux recruter du personnel
soignant et non soignant et augmenter
les salaires
merci merci cher collègue monsieur
rapporteur
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable à cet amendement de
suppression dépit des craintes légitimes
en particulier celle d'un déclassement
de certains établissements périphériques
notre commission a soutenu dans la loi
santé la réforme des hôpitaux de
proximité ce modèle peut s'il est
réellement innovant contribué à faire la
nécessaire liaison entre la ville et
l'hôpital est pour l'heure même si nous
regrettons de décider du financement
sans avoir toute la visibilité pour le
reste notamment sur la gouvernance
il nous semble que la réforme proposée
permettra de sécuriser ces
établissements madame la ministre
oui monsieur le président en effet le
vote proposition consisterait à
maintenir les établissements dans le
droit commun c'est-à-dire la seule
tarification à l'activité
le nouveau modèle de financement est
pourtant bien plus favorable pour ces
établissements puisqu'il permet d'une
part de sécuriser la recette actuelle en
appliquant une garantie pluriannuel de
financement sur toutes leurs activités
de médecine et d'autre part de leur
conférer des nouvelles marges de
manoeuvre en créant une dotation de
responsabilité territoriale pour
financer les nouvelles missions prévues
par la loi au ts en articulation étroite
avec les acteurs du territoire au
premier rang desquels laisser pts
j'ajoute que 100 millions d'euros ont
été prévus dans la construction de
l'ondam pour sur 2020 et 2021 pour
accompagner la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme des hôpitaux de proximité donc
j'aime et un avis défavorable sur votre
à mon nom merci madame jouanno pour
explication de vote
oui nous avons eu déjà ce débat au
moment de la loi de santé
alors je voudrais simplement dire que si
certains ont quelques appréhensions par
rapport à la mise en place des hôpitaux
de proximité
certains autres territoires et même
certains établissements y voit plutôt
une opportunité une opportunité
justement pour construire des liens
entre la ville et l'hôpital
surtout au moment où justement on
construit aussi les communautés
professionnelles territorial de santé
c'est à dire que c'est ce lien entre la
ville et l'hôpital
et puis c'est aussi surtout on entend
hôpital de proximité c'est surtout
répondre aux problèmes épidémiologique
je dirais de la société d'aujourd'hui
avec des malades qui ont des malades
pluri chroniques et qu'il faut prendre
en charge et donc l'hôpital de proximité
pourra répondre tout à fait à la
question vous vous posiez tout à l'heure
madame grès hommes sur justement la
prise en charge des personnes âgées
voire handicapés etc sur le territoire
justement que ces propositions naîtront
et pour rassurer aussi ma collègue
nathalie goulet je l'aiderai dire que
c'est vrai que là la difficulté c'est de
construire une gouvernance qui soit
suffisamment pluripartite si je puis
dire et il faut aussi qu'il y ait dans
la gestion de ces hôpitaux de proximité
comme dans les j'ai acheté des élus
qu'ils soient attentifs justement à
l'achat local qu'ils soient attentifs à
l'organisation territoriale et donc il
faut avoir cette pertinence de
gouvernance qui soit partagée entre
effectivement les professionnels de
santé les élus et l'ensemble des
institutions
merci madame lienemann pro explications
de vote
oui chers collègues
moi je crois que nos concitoyens ne sont
pas dupes de la propagande
c'est de la propagande
on nous explique qu'il ya des angles des
hôpitaux de proximité
ça va être deux vagues ce centre de
soins axa sera pas des hôpitaux de
proximité il y aura pas suffisamment de
services pour répondre aux besoins
hospitaliers de proximité
deuxièmement où vous dis à vous on va
investir dans l'hôpital
on nous vend un plan dont tous les
spécialistes savent que c'est à des
années lumière de ce qui est nécessaire
je prends un exemple de mensonges on
nous dit on va reprendre un tiers de la
dette
grosso modo 10 milliards et donc on va
vous donner pour l'horizon 2020 800
millions de marge de manoeuvre
faux la fédération hospitalière de
france dit que les annuités de la dette
va ce qu'on paye chaque année sur les
dettes des hôpitaux
ça fait 850 millions si vous le dit
viser est pour l'ensemble de la dette
comme on n'en prend qu'un tiers va vous
arriver à 90 millions donc on est dans
un système quand vous comparez c'est
bien 90 millions quand vous
un tiers non un tiers de 850 inter de
850 300 390 bon disons 300 et 300
millions au regard des problèmes que
nous avons et au regard des 84 milliards
d'un budget des hôpitaux mais c'est des
cacahuètes et le plus grave dans cette
affaire c'est qu'en plus elles ne sont
donnés aux hôpitaux que s'ils vont
suivre la fameuse feuille de route durée
annuelle que vous voulez de restriction
des dépenses
parce que par ailleurs les français
croient qu'il ya plus d'argent l'hôpital
non c'est pas vrai il y en a 800
millions d'économies puis on a libéré
quand même 200 millions cette année
supplémentaire
donc la réalité on est en train de faire
on est dans un jeu de deux complètement
de dupes et moi je vous le dis ça va mal
se terminer pour notre démocratie
ça va mal se terminer pour notre système
de soins et pour notre démocratie
alors faute et des crédits en jean louis
maya vendue hôpitaux de proximité
les français vont croire et vont
découvrir que rien de tout ça se pose ce
poste réalise et qu'on les troncs et bas
nous ne pouvons pas faire un vote qui
trompent les français
merci sarko avec ma famille autain
président moi je vais voter contre cet
amendement pour plusieurs raisons je
pensais aujourd'hui où les certains
hôpitaux dits deux hôpitaux de proximité
en tous cas les hôpitaux que nous avons
sur nos territoires les plus éloignés
sont des hôpitaux aujourd'hui qui sont
en dévitalisation et le ramener des
financements différents financements qui
sort de la t2a leur permettre d'avoir
une visibilité pluriannuelle et
permettre aussi de travailler en lien
avec la ville sur le sous la forme dont
les hôpitaux enfin le le cahier des
charges de ces hôpitaux de proximité et
pour bon nombre d'entre eux et c'est eux
qui le disent une véritable opportunité
on doit pas visiter les mêmes hôpitaux
je vous invite d'ailleurs et j'aimerais
bien vous invitez jeu
je vais nommer je vais vous inviter sur
l'hôpital de pont-à-mousson je suis allé
voir ya pas très longtemps qui était un
hôpital où le les élus locaux n'y
croyait plus tellement où la population
ni aller plus ils se sont de manière
volontaire dans un projet de santé
labellisé hôpital de proximité
aujourd'hui c'est un hôpital qui a tissé
des liens importants avec son chu dont
les gardes sont assurées où il ya des
consultations avancées et qui a retrouvé
la confiance de sa population donc je
dis pas que tous les hôpitaux pourront
se reconvertir mais je pense que c'est
une opportunité que certains saisiront
et sur ce fait donc je crie contre
l'amendement
et je soutiens cette démarche de
labellisation merci malgré home alors
moi j'entends bien tout à l'heure on me
dit il faudrait être rassurés moi je
suis pas rassuré du tout on parle de
fermeture d'hôpitaux de proximité de
fermetures de services on parle de
maternité qui ferment
d'ailleurs je peux vous dire que je peux
pas être assurée vu qu'on met en place
des nuitées d'hôtel pour les pour les
femmes qui soit assad qu'ils habitent à
45 kg 40 5 minutes d'une maternité alors
excusez moi moi je m'inquiète quand même
pour l'avenir l'avenir des hôpitaux
merci madame de roche oui merci
nous nous ne voterons pas cet amendement
de suppression
néanmoins je voudrais dire que l'article
il prévoit un financement que cet
intérêt d'être à la fois pas simplement
l'activité mais aussi une dotation par
rapport à la population
néanmoins ce que l'on vote il faut
savoir que il ya quand même des grandes
inconnues qui reste et on l'a dit on
l'avait dit en commission lors de la
première lecture c'est qu'il y en a pas
pour l'instant les ordonnances qui vont
définir la gouvernance de ces hôpitaux
et on n'a pas les ordonnances qui vont
définir les statuts des médecins parce
que ces hôpitaux de proximité c'est bien
dans la loi définit comme quelque chose
qui allie médecine de ville et hôpitaux
de proximité et les auditions que l'on a
faits nous ont montré que les
professionnels de santé pour l'instant
ne savait pas trop comment
s'articulerait et notamment commencerait
le statut des praticiens à l'intérieur
donc pour le financement en effet on le
vote on avait aussi soutenu la notion de
capitaux de proximité mais
une fois de plus on fait quand même un
peu dans les comme à chaque paire fss
certains chèques en blanc sur certains
articles
mais nous voterons néanmoins là et
madame cohen pour explication de vote
moi je trouve que mes collègues ont une
confiance assez aveugle sur dd suivant
les gouvernements d'ailleurs qui se
succèdent avec des chèques en blanc sur
des propositions qui ne fonctionne
absolument pas mais on continue et sur
les hôpitaux de proximité
mes chers collègues il peut y avoir
effectivement un ou deux établissements
pour qui ça peut effectivement
fonctionné mais la majorité des
établissements parce que quand on fait
la loi ont fait la loi pour tous et
toutes ne sont pas dans ces situations
là que fait le gouvernement
sous prétexte d'une démographie en berne
sous prétexte d'assurer ce qui est juste
la sécurité aux patients on va
restreindre on va restreindre les
services dans les hôpitaux et dans les
hôpitaux dits de proximité
alors on va nous dire pour nous vendre
le dispositif ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est pour mieux articuler la médecine
de ville
et puis la médecine hospitalière mais il
m'est cher collègue
si l'hôpital en est là où il en est
aujourd'hui dans une crise profonde
c'est parce qu'on lui demande beaucoup
et notamment à supplée au à la main à la
médecine de ville et dans des
territoires bon nombre de territoires
qui sont des territoires ruraux des
territoires périurbains et urbain il n'y
a plus de médecine de ville et donc
comment voulez vous faire un maillage
avec un hôpital qui va être réduit à sa
plus simple expression par des services
qui ne seront plus rendues avec une
médecine vie où il n'ya pas presque plus
de généralistes et encore moins de deux
spécialistes
on nous vend des rêves donc ça ne va pas
il faut au contraire essayer de
renforcer les services de créer des
passerelles effectivement qui vont faire
que des médecins puissent se déplacer
d'un grand centre hospitalier à un autre
et puis essayer de favoriser parce que
les collectivités de toutes sensibilités
politiques
aujourd'hui
sont acculés à essayer de trouver des
solutions il y à un partout sur tout le
territoire quelle que soit la couleur
l'étiquette du maire des recherches
n'ont pas seulement pour ouvrir des
maisons de santé pour ouvrir des maisons
de santé pour ouvrir des centres de
santé pour essayer justement d'offrir
des soins de qualité sur l'ensemble du
territoire
donc c'est ça qu'il faut soutenir ces
initiatives là et pas continuer à
appauvrir et un nous vendre des choses
qui n'existent pas en réalité sur le
territoire merci chers collègues le
président milan merci monsieur président
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
probablement un peu un peu tout dans la
confusion puisque on a mélangé
j'ai acheté un boulet on a mélangé fhf
madame lienemann on a mélangé t2a on a
mélangé budget global on a mélangé
hôpital de proximité etc etc alors
clairement les difficultés de la de la
santé les difficultés d'un médecine vous
savez tous on en a beaucoup parlé en
commission viennent de différentes
décisions qui ont été prises depuis
maintenant plus d'une vingtaine d'années
quand même la première d'entre elles
étant évidemment les 35 heures et je
reviens dessus sans condamner les 35
heures mais en disant bien clairement
que les 35 heures n'ont compensé au
niveau de l'hôpital non compensés mais
par des gouvernements qui sont des
gouvernements de votre côté des donc des
35 heures non compensés à l'hôpital ont
entraîné d'autres des problèmes majeurs
à l'hôpital problèmes de personnel qui
ont dû évidemment comme y avait une
diminution de personnel diminution de
temps rires le travail qu'ils ont dû
reprendre le travaux d'autres personnes
qui n'ont pas été embauchés pour cela et
les compensations d'été fait ensuite par
un gouvernement de majorité qui a décidé
la suppression d'un permanence des soins
la part de la médecine libérale monsieur
mattei donc clairement nous avons aussi
la responsabilité sur la situation
catastrophique que l'on dit
catastrophique de la santé en france
parce que malgré tout quoi que l'on dise
nous sommes encore très bien soignés sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
nous sommes encore grâce évidemment
à l'ensemble des professions de santé
nous sommes encore nettement mieux
soigner que dans beaucoup d'autres pays
en europe en particulier mais en
attendant donc il y a des difficultés
alors madame la ministre a présenté le
projet d'hôpital de proximité sur cet
article qui a très bien été défendu par
catherine de roche
j'ai été rapporteur de la loi santé je
vous ai demandé de voter parce que je
considérais c'est une bonne loi
d'organisation du travail entre les
professionnels libéraux et les
professionnels de santé publique
il n'en demeure pas moins vrai que c'est
toi ne pourra être efficace que si à
côté
dans le cas des pf et c'est ce qu'on
donne les moyens nécessaires pour que
cette loi soit mise en application d'une
manière complète le fait de dire t2a
pour les hôpitaux de proximité puce
budget global parce qu'en gros c'est ça
une partie du budget global une partie
t2a pour essayer de voir comment ça
marche ok sur le principe c'est
certainement très bon mais apprendre à
voir au niveau de l'addition comment ça
va se faire et dire aussi qu'il faudrait
un ondam à 5
c'est l'idéal c'est évidemment idéal
mais faut dire aux gens qui sont là qui
nous écoute que si à main armée un ondam
à 5
ça veut dire qu'il faut accorder à
l'ensemble de la santé 8 milliards de
plus chaque année
comprendre dans les poches peut-être à
la rigueur du président de lvmh la
première fois mais après quand on leur a
pris une fois on pourra pu les prendre
faudra les prendre ailleurs ce sera dans
leurs proches qu'on le prendra
c'est pas sûr qu'ils soient d'accord
pour le faire merci monsieur le
président donc je mets au voile
amendement 200 avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements identiques le 91 madame mélo
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la réforme
des hôpitaux de proximité s'accompagne
d'une transformation de son modèle de
financement qui est inscrite au plfss
pour 2020 cette évolution du financement
est rendu nécessaire par l'incapacité du
modèle actuel instauré en 2016 assurer
la stabilité et la pérennité des
ressources des hôpitaux de proximité
en effet si le modèle de 2016 comporte
une garantie de financement pour les
hôpitaux de proximité
celle ci est liée au volume d'activité
réalisé
et n'assurent pas un pratique la
stabilité des ressources des
établissements les hôpitaux de proximité
située dans un bassin de vie peu
dynamique du point de vue démographique
voir leur activité stagner et leurs
ressources diminuent en conséquence
d'année en année le déficit cumulé des
hôpitaux de proximité a dans ce contexte
doublé entre 2015 et 2018
pour éviter que les mêmes causes ne
conduise aux mêmes effets et avant afin
d'assurer une véritable stabilité des
ressources des hôpitaux de proximité
il est proposé de ne pas lier le niveau
de leurs garanties pluriannuelles de
financement au volume d'activité réalisé
jeu d'odile 136 merci monsieur
rapporteur ce président ces amendements
soulève donc des inquiétudes légitimes
mais la commission a demandé demande son
retrait ou un avis un avis défavorable
parce que l'intégration la notion de
volume d'activité dans le mode de calcul
suscite des interrogations bien sûr mais
pour autant ils ne sont pas illégitimes
d'intégrer dans une certaine mesure une
composante activité dans ce financement
afin de pas pénaliser les établissements
dont l'activité elle même les dynamiques
donc madame la ministre peut-être pourra
nous apporter des assurances sur l'
équilibre entre les différents critères
qui seront prises en compte
merci d'un ami est oui en effet je
mettrai le même avis que monsieur le
rapporteur vous ne demandez des critères
le texte est soumis à discussion que ce
texte soumis à discussion propose quatre
critères de fixation du niveau de cette
garantie
ce sont les recettes historiques les
besoins de santé du territoire les
qualités de prise en charge et enfin le
volume de l'activité
donc ce dernier critère le volume de
l'activité n'est pas le seul paramètre
de fixation de la garantie est bien au
contraire elle vise justement à ne plus
faire dépendre les ressources hôpitaux
de proximité sur cette seule variable
merci madame lehman pour explication de
vote
je voudrais en même temps que dénoncer
la tarification à l'acte puisque en fait
c'est ça qu'on découvre en partie c'est
que ce système ne marche pas
c'est qu' il n'est pas vrai monsieur
millions que l'on soit dans insiste eu
dans une situation où le sait les 35
heures conte détériorer la situation de
l'hôpital public c'est la réforme que
vos amis ont fait en 2000 ils ont d'une
part mis la tarification l'acte dont on
voit à quel point elle a servi à réduire
les capacités d'intervention de nos
hôpitaux et deuxième en deux ans dans
bien des cas elle ne prend pas en compte
la spécificité de l'hôpital public et
des services qu'il rend au delà des
actes et la deuxième chose c'est vous
qui avez ouvert la boîte de pandore du
fait que les ce soit les hôpitaux qui
emprunte directement aux banques et que
ce soit plus l'état qui verse pour
l'investissement de l'argent qu'ils
empruntaient lui même oria 2 % d'écart
entre le poste dans la khl dans la durée
entre l'emprunt réalisé par l'état
évidemment 2% - que par rapport à ce que
les hôpitaux emprunte ça coûte à la
nation donc il est au d aujourd'hui on
dit bah ils sont surendettés et c'est
sans parler de la crise financière où
certains hôpitaux prix des des prêts
toxiques et autres et autres joyeusetés
donc la réalité c'est que les dés c'est
cette réforme là qui commence à être le
grand tournant libéral dont on voit jour
après jour la détérioration
alors les 35 heures ont été mal préparée
dans l'hôpital trop tardivement
sans qu'on ait formé des assistés des
infirmières des personnels et des aides
et médecins en quantité suffisante pour
y faire face
j'en conviens mais ça fait 20 ans et
c'est pas la source de nos maux
déterminant aujourd'hui merci chers
collègues
donc je ils sont pas retirés sont
maintenus les amendes bombe
madame mélo
il est retiré le 91 236 est maintenu le
centre aussi s'est maintenue dont je
mets aux voix avec un doublage avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 92 malade mais l'eau oui
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues des services
d'urgence traverse une grave crise en
france le maintien ou la création de
services d'urgence et où d'une équipe de
smur
durant la journée semble nécessaire
lorsque les hôpitaux de proximité les
territoires sont éloignés des centres
hospitaliers régionaux ou des centres
hospitaliers universitaires cet
amendement vise à renforcer la présence
de l'offre de soins sur l'ensemble du
territoire en proposant que la dotation
de responsabilités territoriales
puissent se servir à la création ou au
maintien dans les hôpitaux de proximité
d'un service d'urgences 2 ou ou d'une
équipe de service mobile d'urgence et de
réanimation
lorsque ces hôpitaux sont situés à plus
de 40 km au chr ou d'un chu merci cher
collègue monsieur le rapporteur oms le
président l'indemnité prévue à vocation
à rémunérer des actes non cliniques des
professionnels libéraux qui
interviendront dans les hôpitaux de
proximité afin de favoriser justement la
liaison ville hôpital elle n'a pas
vocation à rémunérer le maintien ou la
mise en place d'un service d'urgence qui
sera d'ailleurs possible dans les
hôpitaux de proximité comme l'a prévu
d'ailleurs la loi santé donc ses
activités devront trouver un mode de
financement mieux adapté et il ne me
semble pas souhaitable de diluer la
portée de l'indemnité ici visés donc
c'est à la vie soit une demande de
retrait soit un avis défavorable de la
part des ministres allez y est favorable
j'ai maintenu ma maison je le retire il
y aura tiré merci donc deux amendements
discussion commune de 122 me scientiste
bien si monsieur le président sur le
ministre grec
cet amendement propose un rapport sur la
revalorisation du coefficient
géographique en martinique guadeloupe
guyane réunion dans le cadre de la
réforme du financement de notre système
de santé
les coefficient géographique majorant
s'applique aux tarifs nationaux et au
forfait annuel pour tous les
établissements de la zone publics et
privés pour compenser les surcoûts
supportés par les établissements de
santé des régions d'outre-mer à
l'exception de mayotte qui perçoit une
dotation forfaitaire les équipements
installés outre mer et les prestations
que plus cher en raison des facteurs
structurels inhérents à l'insularité et
à l'éloignement géographique comme les
frais de transport le climat et les
aléas climatiques qui dégrade très
rapidement les infrastructures
l'importation de certains médicaments ou
bien de consommation
les surcoûts de personnels etc le
rapport d'information fait au nom de la
délégation outre-mer sur la situation
des chu de la guadeloupe et de la
réunion démontre que les coefficient
géographique ne sont plus adaptés à la
réalité des coûts locaux et doivent être
revalorisées
cette revalorisation apparaît comme un
préalable indispensable à toute autre
mesure dans un contexte où la réduction
des déficits est l'une des priorités
augmenter ses coefficients contribuerait
à réduire les charges voix a annulé le
déficit de la plupart des établissements
de santé de ces territoires d'outre-mer
cet amendement vise donc à souligner
l'urgence extrême de la situation qui
nécessite une juste revalorisation du
coefficient géographique sans délai
merci le 66 madame à l'est
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le président de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
il s'agit aussi du coefficient
géographique en effet il y a un
coefficient géographique s'applique au
tarif de séjours hospitaliers et qui
valorise des facteurs spécifiques
affectant de manière permanente et
substantielle les coûts des prestations
de santé sur un territoire donné
ce coefficient qui majore environ 2 65 %
des recettes des hôpitaux est appliquée
aux régions d'outre-mer pour tenir
compte des surcoûts structurelles et de
leurs établissements de santé mais
cependant il est resté quasiment
inchangé à la réunion il n'a augmenté
que d'un point en dix ans
contrairement à ce qui a été pratiqué
pour la corse où les autres dom cette
revue libération demandé est une
condition pour que la stratégie
sanitaire déployés par le gouvernement
dans les outre-mers trouve sa pleine
efficience et que les établissements de
la réunion s'installe durablement dans
le paysage hospitalier français comme
des pôles d'excellence
cette proposition de revalorisation du
coefficient géographique permettrait aux
chutes de la réunion de disposer de
moyens adaptés à la santé des familles
réunionnaises et de donner des
perspectives plus positives aux malades
qui souffrent et au personnel soignant
qui subissent des conditions de travail
compliquées
je vais aussi signalé qu'il ya une
épidémie de dengue et qu'une etc les
visées de deug en une année ses 2500
passage supplémentaire aux urgences je
vous remercie en porter monsieur le
président sur la demande de
l'amendement de monsieur antiste la
demande nous semble légitime mais elle
est déjà satisfaite scientiste parce que
par l'alinéa inséré par l'assemblée
nationale dont la rédaction actuelle me
semble suffisamment efficace
exceptionnellement la commission n'a pas
demandé d'ailleurs la suppression de ce
rapport pour que l'évaluation des
positions géographiques outre-mer soit
effectivement mené sur l'amendement de
madame danak que madame mal et viennent
défense
il me semble que la demande de rapports
prévus par bien dit et que les
coefficients géographiques sont
aujourd'hui sous-évalué ou mal évalué et
donc ça n'aurait guère de portée de
figer ici une conclusion sur le niveau
précis auquel il faut fixer ces
coefficients qui peuvent d'ailleurs
varier d'une collectivité à l'autre donc
le procès dont d'abord à l'évaluation de
la situation
mais comme nous sommes attachés à ce
sujet la commission a souhaité avoir
l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement
merci un ami str sur le président les
avis seront les mêmes en effet une
demande de rapport un engagement de la
ministre avec un amendement adopté à
l'assemblée nationale qui demande au
gouvernement de remettre un rapport
d'ici un an sur ce sujet là et qui
permettra d'évaluer en fonction
d'évaluations voir augmenter si besoin
les coefficients et à juste titre chaque
collectivité où chaque territoire
d'outre-mer était en différend
peut-être qu'il aura aussi des
évaluations affaires et d'augmentations
indifférenciée donc sera un avis une
demande de retrait ou sinon un avis
défavorable
merci ils sont maintenus monsieur lurel
pas monsieur on this plus tôt lundi
matin
l'explication de vote je pense que c'est
l'anti se fera rendre à la décision
ultime
mais j'aimerais dire à votre rapporteur
général il ya madame
la ministre a fait plus d'une dizaine
d'années que cette affaire est posée que
des solutions sont imaginé que des
rapports sont faits en rapport aubert a
été récemment remis que la délégation
sénatoriale aux autres m on n'a parlé
que tous les parlementaires évoquent la
chose est celui qui vous parle j'ai eu à
le vivre
j'étais président de région et il y
assure des médicaments je conseille ce
seul exemple arrivant aux autres mais il
ya l'octroi de mer j'ai voulu faire un
geste et non pas simplement demander à
l'état de faire des efforts on a exonéré
toute une panoplie de médicaments une
kyrielle de médicaments de l'octroi de
mer
en fait on a enrichi deux centrales
pharmaceutique
ça ne s'est jamais répercutée dans le
prix du médicament est en tout cas aux
patients ni même pour les hôpitaux
vous prenez les transports vous rendre
les evasan vous prenez la majoration de
traitement dans les autres il y à des
surcoûts partout alors je comprends bien
que une chose a été faite à l'assemblée
nationale votée à l'assemblée nationale
mais demandez encore des rapports pour
évaluer le montant du choco 31% la
réunion je crois que ça louette 27% à la
martinique et en guadeloupe
il est à mon sens urgent de décider
alors leurs collègues dentiste décidera
et le groupe décideront décidera mais
bon il ya manifestement urgence a décidé
c'est donc il se meut scientiste oui je
veux bien entendre que la demande a été
faite à l'assemblée nationale mais je
voudrais savoir en quoi de demandes gêne
il vaut mieux d'eux qu'une donc je
propose aux collègues de voter mon
amendement
il est maintenu et le 122 avec un double
avis défavorable commission gouvernement
qui et pour qui et qui est pour
le 122 1 on parle de 122 à l'attaqué
pour le 122ème bien la main qui et
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté jeux jeux mais je vois le 66 qui
est pour le 66 avec un double avis
défavorable qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté je me revois l'article 24
pas trop mal roulé président c'est une
explication de vote sur la tique 24 oui
donc moi je vais je vais évidemment voté
cet article 24 mais je voulais dire au
président de la commission que je
n'avais pas du tout fait confusion entre
les hôpitaux de proximité et les groupes
hospitaliers territoriaux mais je
voulais simplement profiter de cet
article pour en parler parce que compte
tenu des conditions dans lesquelles on
vote ce texte
aujourd'hui je n'avais pas d'autre
opportunité de faire ses observations je
remercie merci pour cette belle
explication de vote
je mets zoo voix l'article 24 qui est
pour l'article 24 qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté à l'article 25
une pelle de parle de madame mélo merci
monsieur le président
l'article 25 porte l'ambition de
réformer en profondeur le financement du
secteur de la psychiatrie longtemps
considérée comme le parent pauvre de la
médecine les troubles psychiatriques
concerne 12 millions de français chaque
année et serait d'après l'om est la
première cause de handicap à l'échelle
mondiale à l'horizon 2020 madame la
ministre je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur la situation des services
hospitaliers de pédopsychiatrie en
corrèze l'urgence dure depuis 30 ans
dans l'allier les listes d'attentes se
rallonge de jour en jour semaine après
semaine et les services n'ont plus les
moyens d'assurer leurs missions faute de
place disponible pour répondre aux
demandes d'hospitalisation des familles
des écoles ou de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance à l'hôpital de vichy le
service de pédopsychiatrie affiche une
liste d'attentes de près de nantes avec
150 demandes d'hospitalisation en cours
les équipes sont proches du burn out et
n'ont plus les moyens de répondre aux
besoins de la population
c'est pourquoi notre groupe a déposé un
amendement visant à prévoir la création
d' équipes mobiles départemental de
psychiatrie et de pédopsychiatrie merci
si l'amendement 202 mcqueen oui merci
monsieur le président l'article 25
prévoit la réforme du financement de la
psychiatrie alors que vous revenez avec
l'article 24 sur la réforme du
financement à l'activité des hôpitaux
la t2a en mettant en place un forfait
populationnelle ici vous faites
exactement inverse
en quoi les conséquences négatives de
l'introduction de la t2a l'hôpital ne
seront pas identiques pour les
établissements psychiatriques mais
également pour les établissements de
soins de suite
il va falloir nous l'expliqué madame la
ministre un rapport de l'igas de 2017
souligné que la progression des
ressources affectées à la psychiatrie de
service public étaient régulièrement
inférieur à l'hôpital généraliste sur
les sept dernières années les ressources
accordées à la psychiatrie publique ont
évolué en moyenne d'un peu plus d'un
pour cent par dons par an soit un taux
d'évolution nettement inférieur à celui
de l'ondam dont vous avez que nous le
critique ont âprement la faiblesse de la
progression de leurs ressources à placer
les établissements de santé mentale dans
une situation économique financière et
sociale extrêmement préoccupante
il y a urgence à rétablir un niveau de
financement pour la santé mentale qui
progresse davantage
malheureusement ce n'est pas votre
proposition puisque vous avez
difficilement débloquer 100 millions
d'euros pour le secteur psychiatrique
nous avons eu l'occasion de parler fin
septembre fin septembre pardon avec
monsieur franck bellivier le délégué
interministériel lors de l'audition par
la commission la psychiatrique souffre
c'est indéniable et il y à vraiment à
prendre des mesures d'urgence en
particulier comme l'a dit ma collègue au
niveau de la pédopsychiatrie et écoutez
je ne sais pas vraiment où vous
et rencontrer des personnels que ce soit
des directrices directeur des hôpitaux
des infirmiers et des infirmières des
aides soignantes et aides soignants dans
le secteur psychiatrie qui vous ont émis
l'idée de vouloir l'introduction de la
t2a dans le dans leur secteur
je pense vraiment qu'on pourra les
compter sur les doigts d'une main quoi
qu'il en soit nous pensons que les
soignants en psychiatrie ne sont pas là
pour enchaîner les consultations faire
du chiffre
c'est déjà précisément ce qu'ils et
elles dénoncent à travers les protocoles
qui pour eux déshumanise la relation
avec le patient quelles sont leurs
demandes plus de personnel meilleures
formations faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent disposer de lits d'aval et
quant à la psycho la pédopsychiatrie
elle est littéralement sinistre est donc
vraiment votre idée n'est réellement pas
une bonne idée
merci madame monsieur le rapporteur
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
à cet amendement qui vise à supprimer la
réforme du financement du secteur
psychiatrique qui est attendue depuis
très longtemps
nous souhaitons toutefois alors que
s'ouvre cette discussion sur l'article
25 faire pas au gouvernement de notre
inquiétude comme l'expérience des
précédentes réformes financières nous
l'a appris
je prends l'exemple notamment des deux
ans du secteur des ehpad
quels qu'ils subissaient une crise et
qui à cause d'une réforme peut-être mal
maîtrisée du financement entraîné des
mouvements de grève inédit
donc je vous incite à la prudence et à
bien maîtriser et à dire a bien échangé
avec des acteurs concernés
merci l'un namyst
si monsieur le président en effet et
vous l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises
cette réforme structurelle du mode de
financement de la psychiatrie qui n'a
pas évolué depuis plus de 20 ans est
indispensable pourrait réduire les
iniquités historique entre secteur mais
aussi et avant tout entre territoires
elle est fortement attendue par les
soignants et les patients rappeler que
cette introduction d'une forme de
capitation de capitation en effet dans
notre système de soins est un véritable
révolution qui va bénéficier aux
établissements aujourd'hui sous dotées
et aux patients qui sont en attente de
soins rappeler aussi en par elle
réforme que les moyens alloués à la
psychiatrie ont d'ores et déjà été
renforcés ainsi 50 millions de crédits
pérennes supplémentaires ont été alloués
fin 2018 puis de nouveau 80 millions de
crédits supplémentaires début 2019 déjà
favorables merci maicon alors là je suis
atterré par les explications parce que
on est en train de parler deux secteurs
qui sont sinistrées et il ya quelques
dizaines de millions qui ont été
débloqués
je vais pas dire que c'est mal
effectivement c'est positif mais c'est
rien du tout par rapport à l'état des
services de psychiatrie c'est rien du
tout par rapport à où on est la
pédopsychiatrie avec des regroupements
d'hôpitaux dé des regroupements de cmp
qui sont catastrophiques
il ya des listes d'attentes énorme il ya
des patients psychiatriques qui sont en
errance dans les rues qui sont dans les
prisons et on nous parle de quelques
quelques 1 millions d'euros
et encore moi y'a un truc qui vraiment
me ça m'insupporte
madame buzyn elle a fini par entendre
alors à la limite plus vite que ses
prédécesseurs qu'il fallait arrêter avec
la t2a
donc elle a commencé à dire que pour les
hôpitaux généralice on a les signes de
réfléchir à autre chose c'est un début
mais là bien on nous dit ça n'a pas
marché dans les hôpitaux généraliste et
ben on va pherson au niveau de la
psychiatrie et ne vous inquiétez pas
messieurs et mesdames les parlementaires
ça va aller franchement c'est n'importe
quoi c'est à dire qu'on va continuer on
va continuer à alimenter le désarroi des
personnels
quand vous allez visiter écouter mes
chers collègues comme vous allez visiter
un des hôpitaux psychiatriques
vous voyez l'état des locaux et aussi le
désarroi des équipes avec et ils le
disent eux-mêmes ya tellement de manque
de personnel qu'ils ont souvent recours
à à la contention alors qu'ils ne
voudraient pas et qu'ils ne le
souhaitent pas ils ont souvent recours à
la camisole chimique alors qu'il ne
voudrait pas qu'il ne le soutenait
souhaiterait pas et là on nous dit vous
inquiétez pas
mais enfin non mais là je comprends pas
là franchement je comprend pas chers
collègues présidents milan oui monsieur
le président merci d'abord je voudrais
redire aux collègues qui manifestent
contre la t2a en psychiatrie que la
situation de la psychiatrie est
absolument dramatique actuellement mais
pas grâce à la t2a grâce à la dotation
annuelle de fonctionnement
donc on a deux en a deux systèmes de
financement actuellement ces hôpitaux où
la tarification à l'activité qui
semble-t-il n'est pas particulièrement
efficace ou la dotation annuelle de
fonctionnement qui elle n'est pas
efficace au niveau de la psychiatrie
puisqu'elle fixe en fait l'activité des
uns et des autres les hôpitaux riches
restent riches même si l'on est une
diminution d'activité les hôpitaux
pauvres restent pauvres même s'ils ont
une augmentation d'activité
donc il ya un problème à régler à ce
niveau là qui probablement ne sera pas
réglée par la tarification de l'activité
ou uniquement par une réflexion
l'activité dont la recherche qui est
fait actuellement de savoir faire un
mixte entre la daf et la t2a et
peut-être d'autres systèmes de 2,2
financement qui sont évidemment à je ne
parle pas quand tu parles ne sait pas
parler jusqu'au bout qui sont donc
certainement à chercher je voulais
revenir aussi sur ce qui est proposé au
décours d'un article dans un père fss
sur la psychiatrie est là je voudrais
m'adresser à madame à nice en lui disant
que en effet la psychiatrie et vous
savez est particulièrement sinistrée ce
qu'a dit madame mélo sur la
pédopsychiatrie sané ça ne rejoint ça ne
fait que rejoindre un rapport qui a été
fait à la demande la commission des
affaires sociales par michel amiel où on
constate en effet que les
pédopsychiatres on manque un peu partout
sur le territoire national et qui a même
des facultés de médecine où il ya plus
de professeur de pédopsychiatrie
donc il ya vraiment un problème majeur
qu'il faudra régler mais c'est un
problème global
et je pense que la psychiatrie a besoin
d'une réflexion globale et elle a besoin
aussi d'une loi spécifique
autant sur son fonctionnement que dans
la formation des psychiatres que
d'information des pédopsychiatres que
dans le financement
de l'ensemble de la psychiatrie et à
peut-être à revoir aussi le problème de
sécurisation qui s'il était bien
il fut un temps n'est peut-être plus
aussi bien maintenant donc faut revoir
tout ça mais dans le cadre d'une loi
globale et c'est ce qu'un peu ce que je
vous demande madame la ministre à ce
sujet là est par ailleurs j'en profite
pour parler rapidement de ce que
certains psychiatres mettre en place et
qui veut je parle je pense en
particulier à fondamentale fondamentale
dont qui est un réseau national qui a
été mis en place par certains
psychiatres
donc j'ai été en tant que politique l'un
des membres fondateurs et qui se
trouvent dans ce plfss avec une
diminution de dotation de 700 mille
euros il serait utile que l'on puisse
toujours aidé ce genre d'association de
médecin psychiatre qui veulent faire
leur travail et qu'ils ne font plus la
psychiatrie comme on le faisait du temps
de la kangoo hôtes et qui fonda
psychiatrie à partir de la génétique à
partir de la chimie je pense que c'est
pas inutile de pouvoir les aider
merci madame istres merci monsieur le
président manaâ triste dans votre
interpellation dans votre interpellation
de vous poser en gros deux questions la
question des moyens
j'entends ce que vous dites peut-être
que les moyens ce pas suffisant mais
faut aussi et vous l'avez à demi-mot dit
il faut le souligner ces sont des moyens
supplémentaires alors que la psychiatrie
en 20 ans a été le grand oublié de la
santé de la santé une façon d'une façon
globale en france
nous apportons des moyens
supplémentaires et c'est le cas c'est
inscrit dans le plfss depuis depuis
l'année dernière ça c'est la première
chose à deuxième chose c'est la
transition je dire les moyens mais
comment on les met en oeuvre ce moyen
vous nous parler d'activité de tes deux
ans il n'a en rien dans cette réforme
cet article est la question de t2a au
contraire nous partons pas de l'activité
nous partons de la dune relationnel du
de la responsabilité populationnelle sur
lequel en plus on va prendre en compte
le fait qu'ici il ya des mineurs il y
aura des moyens supplémentaires parce
que la prise en charge doit être adaptée
elle sera pas la même
donc cet amendement à 7,7 pas dans cet
article répond vraiment à ce
qu'attendent les soignant et les
patients
merci au ministre donc je mets au voile
amendement 202 avec un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté l'amendement 93 m et
l'eau
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues cet amendement vise
à permettre la création des clips mobile
de psychiatrie de pédopsychiatrie à
l'échelle départementale
ces équipes mobiles pourrait intervenir
à la demande du médecin traitant au
domicile de patients psychotiques
refusant de rencontrer un psychiatre
afin d'améliorer le suivi médical du
malade
ces équipes pourraient également
rencontrer les enfants et des équipes
des centres départementaux de l'enfance
ou des maisons d'enfants à caractère
social afin d'améliorer la prise en
charge et de suivi d'enfants malades
notamment dans les départements
présentent un manque de lits un
établissements spécialisés
je voudrais dire à monsieur le président
de la commission que je le rejoins
parfaitement lorsqu'il parle d'une loi
globale pour la psychiatrie je crois
qu'il va falloir y arriver mais dans
cette attente il faut bien trouver une
solution et patienter et traiter
vraiment les problèmes il monsieur le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le président madame mélo
cet amendement qui vise à préciser le
critère de dotation populationnelle en y
intégrant les équipes mobiles
départementale comme vous l'avez rappelé
bien que je comprenne son intention et
ne paraît pas opportun de viser la
dotation établi selon des critères
régionaux et répartis par les ars pour
intégrer des facteurs qui soit plus
spécifiques au département le recours
aux équipes mobiles départemental de
psychiatrie dont je soutiens et dont
nous soutenons plus exactement le
déploiement doit être pleinement
intégrés à la discussion des plans
territoriaux de santé mentale et je
pense que c'est non adaptés d'en faire
une variable de financement des
établissements
donc c'est un avis défavorable avec
merci nana mistre défavorables aussi
merci les retirer aux mathieu je vais me
retirer mais en espérant pouvoir trouver
une solution comme vous le dites pour
prendre en compte ces propositions merci
chers collègues il retirait dont 206
malabry sommes alors l'article 25 du
plfss prévoit une réforme en profondeur
du système de financement du milieu
psychiatrique procès la dotation
populationnelle serait assis réparties
entre les régions
en tenant compte des différents critères
sociaux et démographiques ainsi que des
besoins psychiatrique des populations à
l'échelle locale
cette réforme loin d'être parfaite a
pour mérite de venir poser les bases à
nouveau système plus décentralisé qui
prendrait en compte certaines demandes
formulées par les structures
hospitalières et psychiatriques dans nos
territoires
mais nous estimons que les nécessaire
d'affiner encore davantage les critères
permettant la répartition des dotations
en effet le maillage des établissements
hospitaliers psychiatriques en france
est-il inégale certaines régions sont
particulièrement isolées notamment dans
les territoires ruraux et montagnards ou
dans les régions ultramarines
ceci manque de personnel
d'infrastructures adaptées et tout
simplement de moyens la question de l'
isolement des régions les plus enclavées
devraient donc être prises en compte
dans le calcul et l'attribution des
financements de la psychiatrie en france
ainsi la facilité d'accès aux soins
n'étant pas la même si l'on habite à
mayotte ou à paris le présent d'un
moment propose de tenir compte dans
l'attribution des dotations aux
populations elles de la distance
séparant les régions isolées de leurs
régions limitrophes
l'objectif d'un tel mécanisme sera
évidemment de favoriser les territoires
souffrent d'un manque à fra structurelle
du fait de la roque l'avenant
géographique
ce dispositif devrait à terme permettre
de résorber l'une des nombreuses
fractures médical ton sous beaucoup de
nos territoires
sinon si cher collègue monsieur
rapporteur ce président bien que la
commission ne soit pas favorable à
l'alourdissement des critères comme on
l'a rappelé il ya quelques minutes
le cet amendement introduit un critère
qui nous semble pertinent pour la
définition des populations des dotations
populationnelle et qui pourrait
peut-être permettre d'oeuvrer en faveur
du décloisonnement entre régions donc
c'est un avis de sagesse que nous avons
émis peut-être qu'on nous remercient la
part du gouvernement
oui monsieur le président la réforme
proposée vise justement à mieux doter
les régions dont l'offre de soin en
psychiatrie est insuffisante l'outre-mer
ou comme certaines régions de montagne
notamment sera ainsi largement
bénéficiaire du rattrapage que nous
allons opérer car le retard pris dans
ces territoires est important s'il
s'agit dans vos propos également de
tenir compte de la densité des
populations au sein des régions alors je
peux également vous indiquer que ce
critère sera effectivement prises en
compte dans l'encadrement national des
critères qui seront utilisés par les ars
pour répartir les financements au sein
des régions donc un non sens là votre
amendement est satisfaisant serait une
demande de retrait sinon un avis
défavorable
merci mme boulet oui mais même le
président monsieur le président madame
la ministre
chers collègues une grande confiance
n'exclut pas une petite méfiance moi je
voterai cet amendement je le trouve très
bien merci
donc je mets aux voileux 206 avec un
avis de sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l'amendement 67 madame a l'air
monsieur le président cette
cet amendement va dans le même sens un
il a il a pour but de résorber les
inégalités en matière d'offre de soin
notamment au sein des départements et
régions d'outre-mer
il faut connaître aussi je vais vous
donner l'exemple de la réunion qui est
un des tous derniers départements
français en moyens consacrés à la santé
mentale moins de 100 euros par habitant
à la réunion contre 130 euros en moyenne
sur l'hexagone
merci monsieur la porter c'est aussi le
même bien vite ce geste
merci madame ministre défavorable je
mets au voile 67 avec un évident sagesse
de la commission d'avis défavorables
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
l'amendement 59 me suis calmé merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
que l'ex est un sujet extrêmement
important que nous évoquons le
financement de la psychiatrie que je
propose
mettre en oeuvre à partir de 2022 merci
rapporteur je crois que on viens de
l'entendre la commission estime trop
prématuré l'application de la réforme du
secteur sans modalités transitoire
transitoire on est d'accord sur les
objectifs d'aucun délai d'un an qui me
paraît tout à fait raisonnable donc avis
défavorable
un avis favorable aux côtés j'entends
j'entends vos inquiétudes je crois qu on
a une urgence à répondre à la question
de la psychiatrie de son financement une
son évolution
nous avons travaillé notre continuer à
travailler avec les professionnels de la
psychiatrie et de ce fait nous savons
que le calendrier resserré mais réaliste
donc ce sera un avis défavorable
merci donc j'aime et aux voiles
amendement 59 avec un avis favorable de
la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté je me
revois l'article 25 et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
baise moi l'article 26 qui est pour
l'article 26 qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté à l'article 26
bis l'amendement 207 noël ou madame line
maintenant chers collègues cet
amendement propose la suppression de
l'article qui vient d'un amendement du
député thomas meissner à l'assemblée
nationale qui vise à maintenir le
financement à l'activité des hôpitaux
t2a que nous avons toujours combattu
mais à une petite nouveauté près c'est
que il ya une pondération selon la
gravité des infections des patients et
l'intensité de leur prise en charge
ce système pourrait paraître judicieux
pour rémunérer les passages de patients
compliqué mais va aussi inciter les
hôpitaux à réorienter plus largement les
patients simple vers la ville alors même
qu'il n'y a pas assez de médecins de
ville comme l'a dit christophe prudhomme
porte parole de l'association des
médecins urgentistes de france
ce retour à fort au forfait de
réorientation et hors du temps
actuellement la dotation est calculé sur
le nombre de passages aux urgences de
l'année précédente et 25 euros sont
alloués
passage son hospitalisation non
seulement cette dotation populationnelle
doit être pondérée par un indice de
précarité afin de prendre en compte les
difficultés sociales mais surtout tant
qu'il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
véritable l'enveloppent des
établissements de santé
on ne peut attendre un miracle de cette
proposition c'est d'ailleurs cette
proposition a été inscrite dans la
mission sur les urgences qui préconise l
un panel de solutions et de propositions
car c'est un ensemble de mesures qui
s'avère nécessaire en amont des centres
de santé en aval des lits et des
personnels supplémentaires
or prendre cette mesure isolément au
lieu d'améliorer la situation pourrait
aggraver les inégalités sociales c'est
pourquoi nous proposons sa suppression
merci monsieur le rapporteur le
président a donné un avis défavorable
parce que la réforme du financement des
services d'urgence n'apportera pas en
tant que tel une réponse à la crise d
urgence mais en moins de caractère
inadapté du mode de financement actuel
des urgences a été relevé dans de
nombreux rapports dont celui d'ailleurs
du sénat de laurence cohen et de rené
paul savary donc la commission n'a pas
souhaité faire obstacle aux évolutions
qui sont ainsi proposés donc c'est un
avis défavorable
merci namyst thème la sénatrice il ya
quelques minutes vous nous avez dit l'
inverse nous avait dit que c'était le
désengagement de la ville qui était la
source de difficultés des hôpitaux là on
vous propose en effet de pouvoir
organiser les hôpitaux
donc il faut être un moment cohérente
dans vos propos je dirais donc ce sera
un avis défavorable
merci banane milman
ce que on dit justement la masse on dit
que le système qui va faire que on
privilégiera les patients compliquées
entre guillemets va reporter les autres
à partie moment il n'y a pas
d'amélioration du de la prise en charge
globale va ramener les autres du côté
des médecins de ville et que justement
il manque et on y fait cette proposition
est dans le rapport de monsieur savard y
ait de madame cohen mais il est en
mesure prise isolément ou de madame
cohen monsieur samarie oui merci chers
collègues savary c'est bien normal de
votre deck à l'entrée mais en tout cas
ce que je voulais dire c'est c'était que
ce que je voulais dire c'est que rizzoli
mans une mesure prise dans un panel peut
être efficace pris isolément elle peut
déstabiliser encore davantage le système
dans un sens négatif
voilà pourquoi nous ne souhaitons pas
qu'elle soit prise isolément
merci chers collègues je me revois
l'amendement 207 avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
138 monsieur juillet merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre cet
amendement vise à assurer une offre de
permanence de soins ambulatoires plus
qualitative en l'adaptant mieux aux
besoins de la population dans son pack
pour la refondation d urgence la
ministre de la santé a souhaité mettre
en place des mesures réformant le
financement de ces services en
l'orientant vers une part
proportionnelle à la qualité à l'offre
de soins existante l'existence d'une
relation forte entre organisation des
soins de ville et activités de services
d'urgence n'est plus à démontrer un
meilleur usage des services d'urgence
passe par une optimisation de l'offre de
soins en ville
répondant à des demandes de soins non
programmés qui doivent être prises en
charge par les médecins libéraux ou les
médecins salariés des centres de santé
actuellement la permanence des soins
commence à 20h alors qu'il serait plus
logique de l'avancé puisque cela
correspond aux pratiques observées de la
population ainsi qu'à une demande
répétée des organisations
professionnelles
au-delà des enjeux financiers qu'il
induit ce dossier nous renvoie la
question de leur maximale jusqu'à
laquelle il est légitime que les
professionnels de santé travaillent à
partir de quelle heure de travail
doit-il être qu'on serre est considéré
comme un service supplémentaire rendu à
la société
il y a aussi un enjeu plus globale pour
notre
système de santé qui est de faire mieux
coïncider les activités hospitalières
notamment des services d'urgence avec
celle de la médecine de ville et c'est
l'objectif portait en filigrane par cet
amendement car comme vous le savez la
fixation des horaires de la permanence
des soins ambulatoires et de nature
réglementaire je souhaiterais donc
madame la ministre évidemment entendre
votre point de vue à ce sujet je
remercie merci monsieur rapporteur
la commission a donné un avis favorable
ce joli et l'amendement posant en effet
un enjeu important celui de dialogue
nécessaire entre les services
hospitaliers d'urgence et les
professionnels de ville manière à
optimiser la prise la permanence des
soins la prise en charge des soins non
programmés
merci nana ministre oui monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur vous
proposait de lier la dotation à la
qualité des services d'urgences à la
paire massa permanence des soins
ambulatoires
votre amendement est certainement un
amendement d'appel sur la question de la
permanence des soins de ville je suis
consciente qu'il s'agit d'un point
d'attention notamment des syndicats de
médecins libéraux
avant toute chose je rappelle que la
permanence des soins est une mission de
service public organisé par les ars en
fonction des besoins de la population et
de l'offre de soins disponibles sur le
territoire
elle fait l'objet d'un cahier des
charges régional arrêté après une
concertation départementale les horaires
de la mission de permanence des soins
sont ainsi fixés au niveau réglementaire
et non dans la loi j'entends les
revendications des médecins libéraux
pour aller plus loin et modifier les
horaires de l'inde et psa nous l'avons
déjà dit nous ne sommes pas opposés à
travailler dans ce sens mais j'insiste
sur le fait que les mois qui viennent
doivent présentement prioritairement
être consacrés au déploiement
territorial décès pts de leur mission
sur les soins non programmés
s'agissant d'un amendement d'appel ce
sera un avis une demande de retrait
selon un avis défavorable
merci monsieur savary oui c'est dommage
madame la ministre parce que ça paraît
tout à fait intéressant la wii peuvent
s'organiser ya pas besoin d'attendre la
loi ni les grilles crédit des règlements
c'est un amendement tout à fait de bon
sens je voudrais dire madame la ministre
c'est que avec laurence cohen nous
avions fait un rapport nous avions été
reçus par le ministère ait jamais eu de
suite c'est dommage vous auriez pu vous
inspirer parce que ce sont plusieurs
mesures qui doivent permettre
d'améliorer la situation et non pas des
mesures ponctuelles fait comme ça hop
tigré tplf ss mais cela va dans un sens
où ça remet pas en cause
en quoi que ce soit les discussion
conventionnelle ni le travail qui peut
être fait en complémentarité entre le
public et le privé
mais là où ils veulent s'entendre c'est
tout à fait normal parce qu'il y aura
une cohérence
on sait qu'après 23 heures il ya
pratiquement par département enfin dans
mon département par exemple 570 mille
habitants il y avait en moyenne
départementale bouin d'un appel entre 23
heures et 6 heures du matin
effectivement il n'y a pas besoin de
mobiliser un tel médecin il peut y avoir
un service organisé
mais avant ou définit la permanence de
soins non pas selon les décrets ou les
règlements mais selon la bonne
intelligence collective locale qui
permet à chacun de s'y retrouver
merci chers collègues donc je me revois
l'amendement 138 avec un avis favorable
de la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté 239 tout se
joue merci monsieur près dans cet
amendement vise à supprimer la
possibilité d'expérimenter un forfait de
réorientation d'un patient par un
service ou unité d'accueil ou de
traitement des urgences qui a été
introduit l'an dernier dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
cette mesure qui a été présentée en
fanfare comme une solution de
désengorgement des urgences semblait
tomber aux oubliettes
et cette année nous avons droit à une
nouvelle proposition en matière de
financement des urgences
la problématique majeure que constitue
l'engagement des pardons l'engorgement
des services hospitaliers d'urgence ne
serait être résolu par ce forfait qui
vise à facturer une prestation
d'hospitalisation pour la réorientation
des patients vers les soins de ville
l'assemblée nationale avait rétabli
cette disposition contre l'avis du sénat
puisque nous l'avions supprimés madame
la ministre vous avez tardé à prendre la
mesure la crise actuelle de l'hôpital
public et les vagues d'annonce qui
engagent des sommes non négligeables
semble pourtant toujours décalé on a
pris l'habitude depuis de dire depuis
une vingtaine d'années que l'hôpital
traverse une crise
or là cette fois ci ne traverse pas une
crise de plus nous arrivons quasiment un
point de retour celui où l'hôpital
public
ça fesse l'augmentation des risques dus
au moins bonne prise en charge mais les
personnels dans une situation intenable
certains changent de métier ou tu le
surmenage surtout ils ne trouvent plus
de sens dans leur métier et le sens du
métier de soignant ce n'est pas d'être
rémunéré pour un acte qui n'est pas
accomplie c'est pourtant ce à quoi vise
le forfait réorientation introduit donc
l'an dernier dans la loi et en plus il
ne s'inscrit pas dans une coopération
pensé en amont entre la ville et
l'hôpital
il est évident que cette problématique
d'engorgement ne pas être peut pas être
résolu par ce forfait est d'ailleurs
interrogé sur cette mesure
les personnels des urgences la rejette
en bloc ce n'est ni digne ni en mesure
de régler le problème
madame la ministre il est plus sage de
supprimer cette disposition
merci monsieur le rapporteur sur le
président le sénat s'était unanimement
opposés lors de du plfss pour 2010 9 à
l'instauration à titre expérimental d'un
forfait de réorientation des urgences
l'expérimentation n'est pas encore
engagé son lancement devait être prévue
en début d'année prochaine
donc par cohérence avec notre position
de l'an passé la commission a émis un
avis favorable à cet amendement
merci mon ami c'est le président
monsieur le rapporteur en effet l
expérimentation sera mis en place dès
début de l'année prochaine
ce cadre expérimental permettra de
nourrir les travaux sur le nouveau
modèle de financement des urgences porté
par l'article 26 bis du présent projet
de loi
l'objectif de ce forfait de
réorientation concours cependant à ce
que cet objectif majeur de recentrage et
d'urgence née d'un constat fort qui est
le 43 % des patients de prise en charge
aux urgences aurait pu être traitée en
ville
les causes de cet afflux trop
systématique systématique aux urgences
sont multiples on cite souvent la
structuration la lisibilité insuffisante
des soins non programmés assurée par les
professionnels libéraux
mais le mode de fonctionnement actuel
des services d'urgence participent aussi
à cette dérive
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons cette
cette expérimentation au crâne avis
défavorable merci même de roche
je voudrais que monsieur le rapporteur
nous re précise son argumentaire parce
qu'on avait voté contre l'an passé vous
avez donné un avis favorable
ah oui j'avais compris défavorable merci
chers jeunes avec la meignanne moi je
suis toujours consterné de voir cette
propension du gouvernement de savoir
tout seul mieux que tout le monde ce qui
serait bon pour le fonctionnement des
services notamment des urgences tous les
personnels sont contre le sénat a voté
contre mais qui est pour
et si vous vous imaginez qu'on met en
oeuvre des méthodes avec un désaccord
total de ceux qui doivent la mettre en
oeuvre
mais où on va par contre tout les
personnels sont tous d'accord que le
sénat est d'accord vous vous êtes jamais
d'accord le gouvernement et donc c'est
quand même un problème qui devient
gravissime cette espèce de mur entre un
état qui saurait mieux tout le monde
elle reste de la population et cet
exemple est flagrant merci chers
collègues dont je mets aux voix pardon
monsieur daumier
juste quelques mots parce que madame la
ministre
moi ça me met vraiment en colère votre
réponse je vous dire très sincèrement
comment vous pouvez ne pas comprendre à
ce point que le fait de payer des gens
pour ne pas soigner ça les choque moi je
veux bien imaginer toutes les solutions
techniques pour éviter l'engorgement des
urgences pour que un pourcentage de
personnes
d'ailleurs vous citez 43% d'autres
études site plutôt 15 ou 20 % qui vont
aux urgences ne devrait pas aller aux
urgences passionnés de te je veux bien
qu'on regarde tous et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs il est temps de mettre en
place une vraie politique sur la pds à
la pds a été rappelé par le prêt dans la
commission a été abolie ça fait
maintenant 15 ans 18 ans 19 ans
l'obligation
il est temps sans doute de la remette il
est temps de travailler de façon
contractuelle et en coopération entre la
ville hôpital celle inverse que vous
faites
d'ailleurs cet amendement n'était pas
dans votre projet il n'a pas été l'objet
d'une étude d'impact
il est sorti
comme ça de la poche d'un parlementaire
de l'assemblée nationale et il porte une
valeur qui est contraire aux valeurs des
personnels qu'ils soient libéraux ou
hospitaliers contraire laisser cette
mesure tombe et vous choquer les
personnels soignants avec votre mesure
merci chers collègues dont je mets au
voir l'amendement 139 avec un avis
favorable de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté je mets ouvre l'article 26 bis
quai pour article 26 bis qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
mes chers collègues il nous reste sans
amendements à examiner
au rythme actuel donc nous ferons une
séance ce soir
ainsi on poursuit à 8h nous n'ont pas
terminé
donc voilà je voulais le préciser pour
les uns et les autres pour vos
interventions
alors je me revois l'article 26 ter qui
et pour qui et pour l'article d'un
système qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté à l'article 27 qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté à l'article 28 l'amendement 19 de
la commission monsieur rapporteur
cet amendement propose la suppression de
la procédure de référencement sélectif
de certains dispositifs médicaux
essentiellement des fauteuils roulants
bien que le dispositif puisse
ultérieurement viser plus large en
raison de trois effets principaux ans
imitant seul élément figurant la lppr
cette procédure court le risque de
manquer sa cible
faute d'englober l'ensemble des actes
techniques réellement facteur de restes
à charge en empêchant tout nouvel
entrant pénétrer le marché
les oligopoles ne manqueront pas de se
former ce qui engendrera inévitablement
à long terme une hausse des prix et
l'injonction qui pourrait être faite aux
sélectionnés de fournir des quantités
minimales de produits et de prestations
sur le marché français ne paraît pas
réaliste au vu du maillage actuel de la
filière du dispositif médical
merci madame la ministre cet article
permet d'avoir des financements
innovants sur des systèmes dont on a
besoin aussi de penser différement et de
regarder ce que l'on peut faire
notamment sur les fauteuils donc
nous avons besoin en effet de pouvoir
garantir aux personnes qui actuellement
parfois au moins un modèle qui n'est pas
garanti par rapport à ce qu'ils soient
adaptés aux besoins du patient avec des
restes à charges élevées face à ce
constat nous souhaitons faire baisser le
prix et diminuer les restes à charge
pour le faire nous avons besoin d'eux
comme je disais de dispositif innovant
de tarification
ils seront innovants pour la france mais
il existe déjà dans d'autres pays
votre proposition de suppression de ce
référencement sélectif revient ne pas
vouloir faire évoluer une situation qui
est bloqué depuis plus de 20 ans et sur
laquelle les travaux précédents de
révision ont déjà échoué dans le détail
peut-être pour vous en donner quelques
éléments sur le périmètre le dispositif
vise dans un premier temps les fauteuils
roulants cette procédure sera limitée
dans le temps et n'empêchera donc pas
l'entrée de nouveaux acteurs elle
sélectionnera plusieurs candidats de
façon à pouvoir garantir
l'approvisionnement et ne pas créer le
monopole
ces dispositifs ne l'est que nous les
travaillons avec les fournisseurs les
professionnels mais aussi les personnes
qui pourront être destinataire donc ce
sera un avis défavorable
merci donc je vais je vois l'amendement
19 de la commission avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l'amendement va de la commission
monsieur rapporteur à s'assurer que la
remise en bon état d'usagé concernera
bien le fauteuil roulant pris dans son
ensemble et non les seuls éléments
inscrits au remboursement de l'assurance
maladie à l'important reste à charge
peut être lié aux dates techniques qui
n'ont pas la qualité de dispositifs
médicaux mais qui sont pourtant partie
pleinement intégrante du fauteuil merci
madame ministre
en effet cette mesure actuelle cible la
prise en charge des dispositifs médicaux
notamment de fauteuils roulants
ils pourront être remis en bon état
d'usagé c'est-à-dire remis en condition
sécurité hygiène fonctionnement après
l'utilisation par une première personne
kidnappée lusage la mesure permet la
prise en charge par l'assurance maladie
de ce dispositif remise en bon état
donc ce sera un avis défavorable merci
donc je mets au voilà mon en vain de la
commission avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté le 95 madame mélo merci monsieur
le président cet amendement vise à
intégrer dans le décret prévu pour fixer
les modalités d'application de l'article
les structures du réemploi qui gère la
récupération la valorisation et
notamment la remise en bon état d' usage
de biens multiples cela pourrait amener
des structures du réemploi a par exemple
réparer et remettre en état des
fauteuils roulants
merci monsieur rapporteur alors par cet
amendement ne paraît pas nécessairement
opportune dans la mesure où la priorité
en matière de remise en bon état d'
usage doit être donnée à des centres
homologué pas forcément des structures
de réemploi quand bien même ces
dernières peuvent être bénéficiaires
d'une homologation donc sam avis
défavorable manas ministre mais
favorable parce que satisfait il est
maintenu il est retiré merci le 34 me
suis mouillé
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
donc le gouvernement a repris un projet
de loi du sénat qui vise à apparaître la
prise en charge donc des techniques de
matériel de fauteuils roulants nous
avions travaillé sur ce sujet là et donc
je peux que saluer cette initiative
concernant la l'utilisation de matériel
remis en bon état de fonctionnement
donc c'est une avancée attendue mais
dans la rédaction actuelle est bien l ac
est aussi des associations du monde du
handicap puisque la notion de libre
choix n'est pas clairement indiqué dans
le texte
alors c'est implicite liée à
l'information et est obligatoire mais je
crois qu'il est fondamental pour aller
au bout de la démarche que les personnes
concernées puissent qu'on savait
réellement le choix entre ces deux
dispositifs tel est l'objet de
l'amendement
merci monsieur rapporteur m'a donné un
avis favorable à ce livre choix
favorable
madame la ministre cet article il est
nullement par question de contraindre le
choix du patient et qui restera libre
d'acheter le dispositif qu'ils préfèrent
nous sommes que le fait de créer deux
d'inscrire avec votre amendement à cette
possibilité
pour et laissant laissé sous-entendre
une confusion donc ça serait plutôt une
demande de ratte de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
merci donc je jeu maison voilà manquent
pas dans madame boulet oui non mais
c'est exactement le contraire monsieur
le président madame le mini c'est un
amendement de clarification c'est pas un
amendement de confusion au contraire je
pense qu'il faut il faut le voter bien
sûr merci donc nous je le mets aux
voileux 34 avec un avis favorable de la
commission et l'avis défavorable du
gouvernement kg et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté le 96 à un
mélo si monsieur le président ce
commandement vise à réintroduire le
mécanisme de consignes proposé par le
gouvernement afin d'inciter les assurés
à restituer le matériel prise en charge
par l'assurance maladie pour qu'il
puisse bénéficier à d'autres assuré le
rapporteur
la commission s'est pas montrée
favorable au rétablissement de la
consigne qui figurait taxe initial et
qui a été supprimée par l'assemblée
nationale
pour donc ça l'avis défavorable pourquoi
le bénéfice d'un dispositif remis à neuf
au versement d'une somme d'argent qu'ils
ne pouvaient donner lieu à aucune prise
en charge de la sécurité sociale la
protection sociale et qui été rétrocédée
aux bénéficiaires au moment de la
restitution du dispositif donc ça
mécanisme qui ne me paraît pas être
opportun donc demande de retrait ou avis
défavorable
na li il est retiré merci chers
collègues trois amendements discussion
commune dont deux identiques le 140
monsieur de 10 merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mme sheikh
collègues deux éléments toutes les
garanties de sécurité de
matériovigilance de sécurité sanitaire
doivent faire l'objet d'une attention
particulière et d'une garantie renforcée
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une personne en
situation de handicap avancée en âge ou
en situation de fragilité
deuxième élément tous les éléments
d'information relatifs à la traçabilité
des matériels des opérations réparation
et de maintenance est d'origine des
pièces détachées doivent être recensées
est disponible afin de sécuriser les
parcours des dispositifs médicaux et
identifier les responsabilités en cas
d'accident douce et amendements je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues de 208 m dames
comme adam brown il en titre c'est
exactement le même que mon collègue un
tous les éléments d'information relatifs
à traçabilité des matériels opérations
de réparation de ma de maintenance
d'origine des pièces détachées doivent
être recensées disponibles afin de
sécuriser
si le 97 madame mélo quasi identique
merci défendu donc monsieur le
rapporteur
en soi tout dispositif à vos souhaits
monsieur le président tout dispositif
conduisant renforcer la matériovigilance
sur un fauteuil roulant remis à neuf par
est intéressant l'amendement propose
tout de même de conditionner la prise en
charge financière du fauteuil âgées à la
traçabilité du moindre de ses composants
ce qui risque de contraintes de façon
importante le travail des centres
homologué pourquoi la commission a
sollicité l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement
merci madame istres l'article prévoit
déjà de créer un système unique de
traçabilité des matériels remis en bon
état c'est une avancée importante pour
favoriser la qualité la sécurité
d'emploi de ces dispositifs médicaux si
nous avons si nous avons introduit le
mot peut-être c'est parce qu'il est
important de prévoir une entrée en
vigueur progressive c'est tout le sens
du peut-être qu'il présente dans la loi
il serait contreproductif de prévoir une
entrée en vigueur immédiate notre sera
un avis défavorable défavorables on
t'avait la commission le rapporteur
votre valise et demander l'avis du
gouvernement donc l'avis du gouvernement
est défavorable donc à vis de la
commission est défavorable j'ai écouté
comme vous tous et donc je dirais
sagesse pour ma part bon sagesse avec un
avis défavorable
donc je mets sauvera les 140 et 208
identique avec un avis de sagesse de la
commission en tout cas du rapporteur et
un avis défavorable du gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
est
ils sont adoptés donc ils font tomber le
97 qui est satisfait en fait le 209
mcqueen en nouvelle lecture l'assemblée
nationale a adopté un amendement
contraignant les industriels a dévoilé
au moment de la fixation du prix du
médicament
les investissements publics en recherche
et développement dont ils ont bénéficié
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour celles et
ceux qui souhaitent comme nous
l'instauration d'une véritable
démocratie sanitaire et par voie de
conséquence de mettre fin à une certaine
omerta
qui règne sur la fixation du prix du
médicament cette première étape
essentielle s'inscrit dans la résolution
sur la transparence
votée en mai dernier à l'assemblée
mondiale de la santé
notre amendement reprend en fait une
proposition de l'observatoire de la
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament car nous sommes conscients de
la nécessité de légiférer dans ce
domaine
comme beaucoup d'entre nous je le pense
le seul regret le sous amendement du
gouvernement qui fixe les modalités de
la transparence à un décret
d'application d'ici janvier 2021 et la
suppression de la prise en compte des
informations fournies dans la fixation
des prix
pour ces raisons nous proposons d'aller
encore un peu plus loin en ne se
limitant pas uniquement aux
investissements totaux des industriels
mais en tenant compte également des
investissements publics en recherche et
développement des contributions plus
publique d'information concernant la
provenance et le coût des principes
actifs et des matières premières ainsi
que des brevets tel est le sens d'un
autre d'un autre amendement et je ne
défendrai pas le suivant qui épouse la
même philosophie
merci monsieur rapporteur alors monsieur
le président l'assemblée nationale a
effectivement adoptés à l'article 29 un
amendement qui permet la publicité des
fonds publics attribués aux exploitants
de spécialités pharmaceutiques en
matière de recherche développement
compte tenu de la sensibilité de ces
données surtout de leur complexité de
leur interprétation un décret a par
ailleurs été prévue
le premier alinéa de cet amendement par
ailleurs à une imputation indiscutable
mais me paraît quand même largement
satisfait la disposition relative au
statut des brevets me laisse un peu plus
perplexe il est vrai que l'alimentation
de la base principale de données
relatives aux brevets géré par
l'organisation mondiale de la propriété
industrielle est alimenté par les
entreprises pharmaceutiques ne donne pas
il faut le dire toute satisfaction en
matière de transparence
pour autant les leviers laisser à la
menthe d'état n'ont pas vocation à
percer excessivement le secret des
affaires
mais à permettre leur intervention
ponctuelle pour garantir l'intérêt
public
c'est notamment le cas de la licence
d'office très peu active et très peu
pardon active et j'en conviens à mon
sens la politique des brevets de
médicaments qui doit concilier le droit
commun l'initiative privée et les
objectifs de santé publique est certes
perfectible mais mérite un travail bien
plus approfondie afin de légiférer c'est
pourquoi la vie du de la commission est
défavorable sur les deux sur 200 et 210
restons sauf 209 madame la ministre
défavorable je mets aux voix pardon
madame cohen
là encore bon d'abord je pense que notre
notre amendement ne va pas voter mais
nous nous des amendements mais nous
allons les maintenir
enfin on s'appuie sur un travail étayé
d'un observatoire de taille
et puis monsieur le rapporteur vous
dites pas ça mérite d'aller plus loin et
cetera web
hélas la ministre nous répond même avis
c'est à dire est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
travail plus approfondi parce qu'il ne
serait pas assez approfondies il ya une
certaine opacité au niveau de la
transparence des prix mais on va
réfléchir
enfin ce n'est pas très sérieux dans le
cadre d'un débat législatif
merci monsieur daumier merci monsieur
présent moi je veux dire que je vais
voter ces amendements parce qu'ils sont
ils sont dans la droite ligne d'ailleurs
des de ce que le chef de l'état a
déclaré lors de la réunion à genève sur
ce thème
on peut discuter j'entends tout à fait
les arguments nécessitant le décret qu'a
rappelé le nôtre rapporteur général
mais toujours est il qu'il ya en la
matière nécessité d'une meilleure
transparence tout simplement parce que
l'opinion publique même sur cette
question de politique du médicament se
pose des questions et que la meilleure
façon de répondre aux questions
c'est de mettre les éléments sur la
table lors d'une audition récente le
président du ccn nous rappeler que les
dividendes les dividendes versés
mondialement par l'industrie du
médicament dépasser les dividendes
mondiaux de l'industrie du luxe
donc c'est pas de l'argent qui est
investi dans la recherche qui avaient
été investis au bénéfice des patients
des données comme ça qui sont exactes
elle nécessite d'être débattue et d'être
mise dans le débat public sur le
médicament
sinon au cristallise un conflit avec des
positions dont on voit qu'elles sont là
finissent par devenir irréconciliables
et qui ne profite à personne parce que
les enjeux du coût de l'innovation du
coût des nouveaux médicaments du coup d
immunothérapie etc
on les connaît ils sont sérieux et donc
il faut accepter ce qui à genève a été
tracé comme perspectives en termes de
transparence sur la question du
médicament et ses amendements vont tout
à fait dans ce sens là sans excès je
dirais collègues n'ont jamais en revoit
le 209 avec un double avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 210 a été défendu il
ya un avis défavorable de la commission
et j'imagine monsieur le rapporteur dans
le monde puisque j'ai la même veine et
même avis aussi pour madame la ministre
donc je mais on voit aussi le 210 avec
un double avis défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté deux amendements identiques
le 106 madame hébert
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre est cher collègue l'article 28
impose la transmission des données
relatives aux prix pratiqués entre les
intermédiaires fabricants distributeurs
en gros distributeurs au détail sur le
marché la liste des produits et
prestations la transparence des données
relatives à la vente des produits
prestations par les exploitants les
fournisseurs de distributeurs au détail
doit être renforcé les pharmaciens sont
volontaires pour participer à ce
contrôle accru néanmoins les organes les
organisations syndicales des pharmaciens
d'officine sont en mesure de transmettre
sur la base d'un panel représentatif des
informations détaillées précisé
suffisante au comité économique des
produits de santé
les modalités de transmission des
données par les organisations syndicales
représentatives sont d'ailleurs défini
dans l'accord cadre avec le cep est ce
donc dans l'éventualité où le ps aurait
besoin d'information plus spécifique
pour une série de dispositifs médicaux
le décret en conseil d'état prévu à la
qui peut l 160 5-2-2 pourrait fixer des
modalités précises de requêtes et de
transmission de ces données
je vous remercie merci mais je leur
apporte un pardon le 141 monsieur denis
puis monsieur le président remercie la
maman est identique on peut considérer
que les et fendues
merci monsieur rapporteur le dispositif
de l'amendement paraît intéressant dans
la mesure où il ouvre la possibilité à
certains distributeurs de faire parvenir
au sexe
un panel de données pertinentes pour
autant la commission a souhaité la avoir
l'avis du gouvernement en la matière en
raison du risque que cette dérogation
pourrait entraîner en matière d'eau
bénite et des systèmes d'information
merci madame istres ce sera un avis
défavorable on nous demande insistent
beaucoup ne demandent plus de
traçabilité sur les prix appliqués l'on
vous propose d'avoir une avancée majeure
justement cette traçabilité et le fait
peut-être de d'avoir une exonération
pour certains exploitants créer une
créerait une inégalité de traitement
entre les différents types d'entreprises
en fonction de leur possibilité d'être
représentés ou non cela conviendrait
cela viendrait également un compliqué
l'exploitation des données entre les
données fines d'un fabricant d'une part
et des données agrégées et provenant
d'un panel d'autres pas donc sur un avis
défavorable
merci du coup la commission monsieur
rapporteur il a demandé l'avis du
gouvernement donc c'est défavorable
donc je mets au voile à mende les deux
amendements 106 et 141 avec un double
avis défavorable commission gouvernement
madame albert pas non le président la
ministre avant de déposer cet amendement
j'ai lu à plusieurs reprises l'article
l'article 28 et j'avoue qu'il était peu
compréhensible les professionnels sont
d'accord pour transmettre ce qu'on vous
propose c'est que ce soit des panels et
les organisations syndicales qui ont
tous les éléments puissent se voulait
les envoyer plutôt que chaque
distributeur le fasse
en fait on regroupe les transmissions
c'est pas un refus de transparence bien
au contraire
on peut y contribuer avec beaucoup de
volonté et que ce soit pas chaque chaque
distributeur qui soit obligé de vous les
transmettre
merci chers collègues dont jeu mais je
voie d'amendement les deux amendements
sont 640 et avec un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient ils
sont adopté l'amendement 35 monsieur
mouillé monsieur président alors pour
moi c'est un moment de précision mais
d'une façon générale l'idée c'est de
donc là cet amendement tend rendre
pleinement applicables aux dispositifs
médicaux remuant bon état d' usage le
droit commun en matière de
matériovigilance ce que le texte initial
ne provoque que de manière très
succincte de nouveau regarder
mobilisation des associations du monde
du handicap jeu qu'on pense qu'il est
nécessaire que le texte soit extrêmement
de pi site et je pense que le
gouvernement tout à l'intérêt de
travailler ses communications de façon à
rassurer les futurs utilisateurs
merci monsieur le rapporteur enfin avis
favorable
dire que le président
le code de santé publique notamment dans
sa partie réglementaire prévoit déjà le
signalement des événements de
matériovigilance c'est au niveau du
décret que les enjeux que ces enjeux
sont aix ont explicité comme c'est le
cas actuellement dans le code de la
santé publique sera un avis défavorable
merci dont je me suis mouillé j'entends
madame les ministres votre remarque et
je comprends que sous l'angle peut-être
juridique mais je le truc que vous loupé
une occasion parce que vous avez
clairement j'ai indiqué que cette
évolution concernant le matériel
remise en état est une réelle avancée et
vous gâcher c'est finalement toute la
démarche et la communication pouvait
faire auprès des acteurs parce que au
lieu de montrer la plus value et avec
les débats autour de votre charge
c'est assez d'inquiéter l'ensemble du
système et vous allez perdre en matière
de communication alors vous avez plutôt
un bon point ce cette démarche là je
regrette
merci donc je me vois le moment 35 avec
un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l'amendement 211 namco a défendu
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
deux avis défavorables dont je le mets
on voit le 211 avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée je
mets aux voix l'article 28 qui est pour
l'article 28 qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté même boîte pour
le 28 bis même vote et adoptée le 28 de
terre même pas nom alors je ne mets aux
voix qui est pour le 28 terre qui est
content qui s'abstient il est adopté
l'article 29 à l'amendement raté un de
la commission monsieur rapporteur oui
c'est mon amendement l'amendement de la
commission
donc il s'agit de remplacer cet alinéa
par deux autres alinéa parce que l'année
s'est pas produit en 2016 à propos de la
substitution d'un biosimilaires une
position très claire
même en cours de traitement elle ne
présente pas de danger particulier pour
autant que cette substitution soit
exclusivement de l'initiative du médecin
non sous celle du pharmacien d'officine
donc l'abrogation qu'opère le texte de
la possibilité substitution par le
pharmacien est néanmoins regrettable car
le contrôle par le prescripteur est déjà
assurée dans la possibilité qui lui est
ouvert de spécifier le caractère non
substituables du médicament biologique
de référence
et par son information obligatoire par
le pharmacien dans des conditions
précisées par décret donc il a été
objecter que le retard de publication de
ce décret empêché la bonne information
du prescripteur
ces délais sont notamment liés à la
montée en charge comme embryonnaire de
la messagerie sécurisée de santé dont il
est prévu qu'elle sera un jour largement
déployée donc le l'amendement revient
sur l'abrogation décidée par le texte en
raison du signal très négatif serait
envoyée aux fabricants de biosimilaires
ainsi que de l'utilité pour certaines
pathologies notamment le diabète d'une
substitution d'un biosimilaires par le
pharmacien d'officine précise que la
substitution peut encore avoir lieu mais
dans le cas de plus sécurisé en
permettant à la nes m doré de la réguler
par des recommandations
merci des analystes monsieur le
président je voudrais le dire très
clairement le gouvernement soutient sans
réserve le développement des médicaments
biosimilaires nous n'avons pas attendu
le plfss 2020 pour agir et plusieurs
mesures incitatives ont d'ores et déjà
été mises en place par le gouvernement
et de nouvelles vous sont proposées
aujourd'hui si nous soutenons leur
développement nous ne souhaitons pas le
faire n'importe quel prix car les
biosimilaires ne sont pas des génériques
oui le plfss pour 2020 on propose de
supprimer la possibilité de mettre en
oeuvre une substitution par le
pharmacien introduit en 2014 et notre
motivation est simple c'est la qualité
et la sécurité des soins
pas plus pas moins et pour essayer de
mettre tout le monde d'accord il nous
faut repartir d'une page blanche je
dirais sur l'interchangeabilité des
biosimilaires et travailler la question
avec les pharmaciens avec les
prescripteurs et avec les passions notre
objectif à tous est le même c'est
disposer des conditions précises pour
garantir le bon usage en cas
d'alternance entre médicaments
interchangeables et je me suis engagé
auprès de l'assemblée nationale a
travaillé la question en n'ayant qu'un
seul objectif c'est l'intérêt des
patients et c'est dans cette attente
conservons le prescripteur au coeur du
dispositif donc sur un avis défavorable
sur votre amendement merci
donc je mets ouvre à l'amendement de la
commission le 21 avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté le 22 de la commission si
monsieur rapporteur s'agit monsieur le
plaisir de la possibilité pour le
ministère de fixer un prix maximal de
cession pour certains médicaments ou
certains produits de santec
oui a suscité il manque quelque chose
l'incompréhension des acteurs concernés
elles attendent une dérogation au
principe équilibrée de la négociation
conventionnelle du prix entre
l'industriel et de ces eps et les
critères susceptibles de provoquer cette
fixation unilatérale dont des cris sont
décrits de façon à être à tout moment
opposable aux industriels op prix de la
loyauté qui régit normalement les
conditions de la commande publique
en conséquence cet amendement renvoie à
la négociation conventionnelle entre
l'industriel et lesieu ps des deux cas
évoqués par l'article 29 en un ministre
défavorable nous je me revois
l'amendement 22 de la commission avec un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté le 212 c'est madame
lienemann il nous proposons de rendre
publics les conventions signées par le
cep est ce comité économique des
produits de santé avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
en particulier quand il y à des remises
accordées cette dernière précision est
extrêmement importante puisque
aujourd'hui le prix facial des
médicaments et publiée au journal
officiel et les informations sur ce qui
est réellement payée par le système de
santé n'est pas réellement disponibles
pourtant les prix du produit de santé ou
un impact direct sur l'accès aux soins
des patients
et si l'industrie pharmaceutique
aimerait continuer de rester dans
l'ombre au motif du secret économique
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens
n'accepte plus ces arrangements entre
amis
il faut établir de la transparence en la
matière car il s'agit d'un véritable
programme projet problèmes démocratiques
et sanitaires merci monsieur rapporteur
alors cet amendement entend rendre
publics des conventions passées entre
l'exploitant pharmaceutique et le sait
au ps et en insistant notamment sur le
niveau des remises
je signale aux auteurs cet amendement
que le rapport annuel d'activités du
crps fait état du montant global des
remises consenties par les exploitants
compte tenu des objectifs de santé
publique de maîtrise des dépenses
d'assurance maladie que doit servir le
cps bien sûr la publicité donc dans ce
cas me paraît tout à fait normal est
essentielle en revanche la phase de
négociation préalable qui fait
intervenir individuellement le cep assez
chaque exploitant relève à la mon sens
du secret des affaires
cet équilibre délicat entre
l'application ordinaire du droit des
affaires et l'activité pharmaceutique
qui reste un secteur d'activité comme un
autre et les objectifs d'intérêt public
spécifique à ce secteur
ce matériel matérialise pardon dans la
nature un peu singulière du seo ps qui
ne se confond pas avec le ministère et
dans la publicité limité au chiffre
global donc que ce sera un avis
défavorable
merci madame istres défavorable je me
revois à l'amendement va 212 avec un
double avis défavorable qui et pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 142e monsieur janvier merci
monsieur près dans l'objectif du présent
amendement et que figure dans le nouveau
bulletin officiel des produits de santé
l'information concernant l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché car elle est loin
de constituer une étape obligatoire pour
tous les produits de santé en effet les
dispositifs médicaux ne sont pas soumis
aux mêmes règles aux mêmes contrôles par
les autorités sanitaires que les
médicaments
la réglementation européenne les
considère comme des objets de
consommation comme les autres car à la
commission européenne ils sont rattachés
à la direction générale des entreprises
et non à la direction générale de la
santé
ainsi tandis que les médicaments ne
peuvent être commercialisés sans une à
mm délivré par l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé
un saint marc hce pour conformité
européenne suffit à commercialiser les
dispositifs médicaux y compris les plus
à risque comme les implants ces derniers
ayant vocation à rester dans le corps
pendant des
anele logique que nos concitoyens
s'imaginent qu'ils font l'objet des
mêmes règles de sécurité sanitaire que
les médicaments
cette situation a été révélée notamment
par le travail d'investigation et mme
plante files conduit par un consortium
international de journalistes mais elle
est la conséquence de plusieurs
décennies de laxisme et de contrôle
passif du marché selon l'expression
utilisée par l'igas dans un rapport
d'audit qui vous a été remis à madame la
ministre
il y a un an une nouvelle réglementation
impulse au niveau européen devra entrer
en vigueur en 2020 mais ne placera pas
les dispositifs médicaux les plus à
risque sous un régime de m
faute d'action plus déterminés des
autorités françaises et européennes
il convient donc de tout renforcé par
tous moyens la transparence pour
permettre aux patients de faire des
choix éclairés c'est l'objet de cet
amendement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors c'est
une idée qui nous paraît bonne
ce joli et donc que la commission a
donné un avis favorable parce que ça va
permettre de faire le départ entre
dispositifs médicaux et ont fait l'objet
d'une à mêmes et les autres
merci madame istres
[Musique]
l'objectif du bulletin officiel est de
regrouper l'ensemble des décisions
relatives à la prise en charge des
produits de santé
or les publications relatives aux
autorisations de mise sur le marché sont
décision de police sanitaire
elles sont par ailleurs déjà rendue
publique sur le site de l'asm
la publication conjointe de décision de
police sanitaire et de prise en charge
me paraît contraire à votre objectif de
lisibilité des décisions donc ce sera un
avis défavorable
merci madame boulet oui moi je vais
soutenir cet amendement parce que la
commission denquête qu'on avait eues au
sénat avec chantal jouanno notamment sur
les implants mammaires avait déjà fait
cette préconisation donc plusieurs
années après je vois pas pourquoi on la
soutiendrai pas alors qu'on l'a proposé
dans ce que dans ce rapport de la
commission d enquête du sénat donc moi
je voterai cet amendement merci donc je
me revois le moment soit 42 avec un avis
favorable de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté je vais aux voix l'article 29 pas
non monsieur le président mi longs
oui merci monsieur président avant de
voter le 29
je voudrais sus attendent sur cet
article poser une question au
gouvernement
celui ci a fait adopter malama ministre
en nouvelle lecture à l'assemblée
nationale un amendement qui prévoit
d'ici à 2022 un mécanisme de transition
lors de la mise à disposition du
spécialités génériques donc la date
d'entrée en vigueur de l'article 66 de
la loi de financement de sécurité
sociale pour 2010 9 qui a institué le
principe selon lequel médicaments
princeps et génériques sont remboursés
la même façon sera t'elle par conséquent
modifié madame la ministre n'ont en
effet parce que le nouveau dispositif
laisse au pouvoir réglementaire une
marge d'appréciation pour l'entrée en
vigueur
nous pouvons donc moduler la date
d'entrée en vigueur pour avoir le temps
d'adapter le système d'information de la
delà de la cnam merci mamie liste dont
je mets au voile article 29 qui est pour
l'article 29 qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté à l'article 29
bis un seul amendement puisque le
deuxième le 79 n'est pas défendu donc il
tombe le 213e cohen merci monsieur le
président l'objet du présent amendement
propose que la production de cannabis à
usage thérapeutique et médical qui sera
expérimentée pendant une durée de deux
ans soit issue à hauteur de 60% de
l'agriculture biologique française
cette proposition est ambitieuse mais
elle se donne deux missions essentielles
premièrement d'offrir une qualité
médicinales irréprochable afin que
l'expérimentation du cannabis
thérapeutique sur le sol français se
déroule au mieux
deuxièmement de permettre le
développement d'une filière française
dans un domaine actuellement inexplorés
par les agriculteurs qui pourrait subir
de plein fouet la concurrence de
filières européennes
de nombreux pays ayant légalisé le
cannabis thérapeutique bien avant nous
notre groupe que ce doux espère que ce
double objectif sera partagée par
l'ensemble des groupes politiques au
sein de cet hémicycle
nous ne voyons pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
le gouvernement ne soutiendrait pas
cette initiative puisque l'exécutif
appelle de ses voeux
le développement d'une agriculture
biologique française et je dois dire que
je vais présenter donc cet amendement au
nom de mon groupe mais que j'ai ce aussi
fortement
ma collègue esther benbassa qui est la
première signataire de cet amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors sur
le président la différence du chanvre
industriel la production de cannabis
thérapeutique se feront climat contrôler
indoor santerre évitera tout résidu de
pesticide
il s'agit d'un mode de production pour
lequel la certification agriculture
biologique n'est donc pas adapté
c'est le cadre d'expérimentations qui
est fixé par la haine et celle qui
déterminera le cahier des charges et
produits de cannabis à visée
thérapeutique dans un souci de
protection de la santé des patients ça
me paraît évidemment aller de soi c'est
un avis défavorable et même avis
défavorable m'ont amené man qui est
présenté il ya deux volets il ya le fait
qu'ils soient produits en france et ya
le fait qu'ils soient biologiques de
l'agriculture biologique
donc il me semble que la partie produits
en france est pas négligeable parce que
pardon
d'accord alors personnellement je
propose un sous-amendement qui enlève
biologique dans la première partie parce
que je pense que néanmoins il faudra il
faudra qu'on soit en situation qu'ils
soient biologiques d'agriculture
biologique à ce qu'il faut pas qu'ils
aient de de compte d'interférences
potentiel dans l'étude sur l'impact
éventuel de pesticides etc
mais au moins qu'ils soient français en
tout cas pour ma part je pense que c'est
la première des choses et qu'ensuite on
soutiennent une filière biologique
française me paraît souhaitable
donc non ça c'est paris voilà donc je
pense qu'on pourrait enlever dans un
premier temps biologique
même si vous l'aurez entend compris
notre groupe et madame esther benbassa
souhaite qu'on développe une filière
d'agriculture biologique en la matière
voilà donc on mettrait la production de
cannabis à usage thérapeutique et
médical doit être issu de l'agriculture
française en retirant biologique
il est rectifié comme ça bien rectifié
comme ça monsieur rapporteur est ce que
ça change quelque chose
moi je voudrais bien changer quelque
chose si si on était certain qu'ils
aient une production française or on me
dit on me confirme que la production
française est très très faible
pratiquement aujourd'hui pour
s'alimenter faux faux production connu
production coluche précise thérapeutique
thérapeutique
ah oui on peut aller effectivement dans
certaines arrière-cour cetera fait
effectivement mais c'est pas de ça dont
il s'agit c'est pas ça dont il s'agit
pendant donc femme semble-t-il donc donc
le problème c'est si on veut favoriser
l'expérimentation
ça sera il faut déjà commencer par avoir
du cannabis français est actuellement il
y en a très très peu c'est
essentiellement du cannabis qui provient
de l'étranger sans merci ne sera pas
deux
j'essaye madame lienemann je ne
plaisante pas j'essaye de m'informer
merci monsieur rapporte je suis pas
compétent je suis sans doute moins
compétents que vous sur ce terrain parce
que j'en ai jamais fumé donc voilà
madame la ministre
s'il vous plaît sous payé cher collègue
madame lienemann
vous vous êtes intervenu vous êtes fait
une explication de vote donc je te
demanderais de bien respecter les
orateurs ça serait bien pour tout le
monde qu'on puisse s'écouter et
s'entendre au nanisme
nous parlons de production qui
répondront aux standards pharmaceutique
on est bien sûr de la production par
rapport à de la production sur un
médicament est pas usage récréatif
actuellement est à ce jour
comme nous n'avons pas de médicaments
disponibles sur notre territoire puisque
nous n'avons pas encore expérimenté ni
même ouvert à l'utilisation
nous n'avons pas de production de
cannabis en france pour nos produits
pharmaceutiques médicamenteux donc rien
n'empêchera de pouvoir en effet quand
dès lors qu'on en sera l'expérimentation
et si on a de la production
d'agriculture biologique française on
pourra l'utiliser mais ça ne sera pas
empêché par le texte de loi tel qu'il
est rédigé
merci donc je mets au voile amendement
213 avec un double a vite rectifié avec
un double avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée je mets au gua
l'article 29 bis maicon mois compte tenu
du débat je fais une explication de vote
sur sur la wii sur l'article parce que
nous allons voter en faveur de cet
article propose effectivement une
expérimentation pour autoriser l'usagé
du cannabis thérapeutique pour certaines
pathologies suite je le rappelle ici un
avis favorable de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament en juillet
dernier ce n'est pas la première fois
que nous débattons de ce sujet nous
avons eu l occasion de le faire
en mars dernier à la demande d'ailleurs
de notre collègue esther benbassa
membres de notre groupe et je crois que
l'on peut saluer cette avancée
scientifique et médicale tant elle a
fait ses preuves dans 17 pays européens
ayant et ayant eu recours
c'est une réponse à la souffrance des
patients pour lesquels les thérapies
classiques ne fonctionnent plus et qui
se retrouve dans l'obligation de
recourir à l'auto culture ou d'utiliser
illégalement des produits issus du
marché noir avec tous les risques que
peut présenter l'automédication cela
peut-être vous faites mieux comprendre
notre amendement est peut-être que vous
regrettez de ne pas l'avoir votée nous
partageons par ailleurs les remarques du
président millions sur le suivi
nécessaire et très régulier des patients
sur d'éventuels effets indésirables et
sur la nécessaire traçabilité à avoir
pour les produits utilisés et provenant
d'entreprises étrangères la france non
commercialisant pas encore puisque la
production de cannabis est interdite
mais cela sera peut-être prochainement
le cas je pense comme l'a dit ma
collègue marie noëlle lienemann au
département de la creuse et à de
nombreuses autres départs territoire
français dans lesquelles dix sept mille
hectares sont déjà consacrés à la
culture du chanvre industriel et qui
attendent beaucoup de la légalisation du
cannabis thérapeutique
cela constituerait un levier important
pour la rue du maine redynamisation
économique de ces territoires
enfin nous vous appelons madame la
ministre a que c'est à ce que cette
expérimentation est plus tard sa
généralisation soit prise en charge
financièrement
et que l'usagé du cannabis thérapeutique
soit remboursée par la sécurité sociale
pour tous ces enjeux médicaux sociaux et
économiques
nous voterons cet article 29 bis en
regrettant évidemment que notre
amendement n'est pas été votée mais
c'est un premier pas je vous remercie
merci marc rossignol seraient remplies à
nos collègues que nous avions eu un
débat très sérieux il y a quelques mois
ici dans cet hémicycle sur l'usagé du
cannabis thérapeutique avec des
réflexions beaucoup plus convergentes et
beaucoup moins détendue et souriante que
celle que nous avons cet après midi sa
première remarque la deuxième remarque
c'est que c'est aussi à moi si je
voterai cet article est mon groupe aussi
j'imagine mais j'invite les cas les
collègues souvent très pointus sur les
questions agricoles souvent très
attentif à la culture à nos filières à
traiter le sujet de la production
française de chambre et cannabis avec
plus d'attention et même si on est
samedi soir et que tout le monde est un
peu détendus merci chers collègues je
mets aux voix l'article 29 bis qui est
pour l'article 29 bis qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté à l'article 34
amendement discussion commune de 128
monsieur savary oui merci c'est un
amendement qui a été proposé par france
aso sentez vous savez que c'est une
association qui regroupe quand même
nombre d'usagers et qu'ils voulaient
attirer votre attention notamment madame
la ministre sur cet article là en ce qui
concerne les athées u11 mediative où il
ya eu un durcissement des critères pour
des raisons strictement budgétaire est
ce que vous ne pensez pas à travers ces
dispositions que cela risque de porter
atteinte
un certain nombre de patients qui
pourraient bien ne bénéficieront pas à
ce moment là des molécules innovantes
contenu
et des athées us est en fait plus un
amendement d'appel qu'autre chose je
pense qu'il ya besoin de rassurer dans
ce domaine là merci chers collègues le
155e ceux d'audi oui merci monsieur le
président mon ami nisme chers collègues
il ce rythme en créer
je fais un petit peu d'histoire face à
l'épidémie de vih sida les athées eu
répondre à des urgences vitales ou à
l'absence de traitement approprié pour
des personnes atteintes de maladies
rares et graves comme bien évidemment le
cancer l'athée nominative est demandée
pour une personne par un médecin d'un
thé ou de cohorte est délivré pour un
groupe de patients répondant à certains
critères définis par l' agence de
sécurité du médicament des mesures
correctrices sont régulièrement proposés
pour répondre à un enjeu majeur félicité
faciliter l'accès au traitement tout en
maîtrisant la négociation des prix et
donc les dépenses les propositions
discutées dans cet article il mettrait
cependant sérieusement l'accès aux
médicaments à des personnes sans
alternative thérapeutique de nouveaux
critères d'octroi des athées ou
nominative durcissent le caractère de
grande gravité et d'urgence de la
maladie ces critères risque de limiter
l'accès aux médicaments notamment
anciens utilisés en at il eu nominative
au long cours
à défaut d'alternative disponibles
maladies rares pédiatrie ou de
laboratoires présents en france
souhaitant les commercialiser une
seconde disposition amènerait à limiter
le nombre de personnes bénéficiant dati
l'umih natives ou delà d'un quota fixé
par arrêté ministériel
les patients serait donc privé de
traitement pour des raisons strictement
budgétaire imposant de sérieuses
questions éthiques
lorsque le quota date est nominative
sera atteint certains laboratoires
seront ils enclins à faire une demande
datée eu deux cohortes question peut
être posée notamment pour des
traitements anciens par ailleurs la
fixation par le ministère du prix des
attributs nominatives
alors que le prix de la paix une cohorte
est libre risque de retarder de façon
importante
l'axé là-encore à certains traitements
les laboratoires attendront d'avoir
obtenu une attitude qu un
un processus qui est plus long et
refusons les demandes ati nominative qui
elles sont décidées plus rapidement ces
amendements visent donc à supprimer ces
dispositions tout en mesurant comme cela
a été présenté dans le rapport à
l'assemblée nationale que certains
médicaments
on a eu nos mii natives sont négociés
façon proposés à des prix exorbitants
par certains laboratoires
c'est aussi la réalité d'où ces
amendements je vous remercie merci chers
collègues le rapporteur le 23 24
alors monsieur le président cette
amendement vise à préciser le cadet
d'éligibilité du patient à la techno me
native l'absence d'alternative
thérapeutique doit s'apprécier au regard
de la poursuite efficace du traitement
et le 24 c'est donc deux mesures de
soit soit pour le premier alinéa 16 une
proposition donc qui définit en fonction
du nombre de cibles de patients
concernés le seuil qu'il faut prévoir
pour les athées ou nominative et pour le
l'alinéa 17 la suppression de cet alinéa
qui parce qu'on peut s'interroger sur la
cohérence du dispositif retenu qui
refuse à un médicament
la techno me native s'ils disposent
d'une première à mêmes mais qui autorise
tout de même son attribution
si le médicament fait l'objet d'un arrêt
de commercialisation et qu'il existe des
forte présomption d'efficacité de
sécurité du médicament dans l'indication
thérapeutique sollicités donc ça nous
apparaît un peu contradictoire c'est la
raison pour laquelle on demande la
suppression de cet alinéa avec la
commission sur le 128 et 155 non pardon
madame la ministre d'abord l'avis de
l'avis de la commission sur les deux
premiers amendements du rapporteur et
est donc sur les deux premiers
amendements ce un avis défavorable
bien que nous partagions certains des
constats de nos collègues nous ne
montrons nous ne nous montrons pas aussi
rigoureux dans la condamnation de la
restriction des ati nominatives et donc
je leur propose de vous rallié à
l'amendement de la commission
merci madame la ministre je j'entends
les arguments sur vous sur vos
différents amendements peut-être vous
rassurer que certains articles n'est pas
un dispositif de rationnement est un
dispositif anti content contournement
pour que la tpu de kort ne soit pas
contourné par rapport à lattes et une
aux mines hâtives
donc là tu es une nomination mais là tu
es une nominative pardon n'est pas
remise en cause donc on est bien sur un
système qui évite le contournement donc
sereine d'un avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble de vous abandonner
merci man de roche merci la madame la
ministre
certes on entend bien ce que vous nous
dites il ya quand même des éléments dans
dans l'article cette notion notamment de
seuil
nous on souhaite vraiment qu'il soit
fonction du nombre site de patients pour
l'indication thérapeutique considéré
parce que sinon si on met un seuil comme
ça de façon arbitraire alors qu'on est
vraiment sur des niches de médicaments
qu'on les a tués nominative c'est
souvent ça ça n'a pas vraiment de sens
donc en fait on on ne
on ne souhaite pas contourner contourner
le dispositif et on est favorable en
efface que soit clairement établie mais
en même temps il faut mettre des
restrictions et des critères qui soit
raisonnable et qui corresponde à la
réalité des choses donc cette notion de
seuil
elle nous semblait elle nous semblait
trop trop rigide et et surtout pas pas
cohérente et pas et pas logique et c'est
pour ça que nous avons présentée ces
deux amendements avec les explications
qu'a donnée le rapporteur j'en profite
puisque il me reste une minute pour dire
que nous souhaitions mais ce n'est pas
possible avec la règle de l'entonnoir et
puisque nous sommes en seconde lecture
nous souhaitions et nous aurions voulu
avoir avec la mine et la santé un débat
important sur l'accès précoce à
l'innovation
on attend une réforme de l'évaluation
qu'avait annoncé à grand renfort de deux
tambours si je puis dire par le premier
ministre lors du xi en 2018 et lorsqu'on
a fait avec vernis guyot termes de dénis
le bilan de l'accès précoce à
l'innovation
les mots ont été importants mais un peu
comme toujours sont suivis de ces peu
d'effet donc on n'aurait pas avoir ce
débat là sur notamment la question de
l'évaluation qui est attendu depuis
depuis des années par les professionnels
et notamment tous les chercheurs aux
touts les équipes soignantes des grands
centres d'essais thérapeutiques que sont
par exemple du cerveau aussi où la
fondation curé ou d'autres bons nous
n'aurons pas ce débat mais ce n'est que
partie remise et nous allons formuler
des propositions en ce sens
prochainement
merci cher collègue monsieur savary oui
ministre il n'y a pas que du
contournement des possibilités de
contournement à travers les mesures que
vous avez pris de combat des mesures de
contournement puisque l'on parle de
quotas fixés pour les ati nominatif
quand même s'il ya un quota ça veut dire
que derrière quand vous sortez des
quotas donc il ya des patients qui peut
avoir les pathologies lourdes et très
très très cher en ce qui concerne le
traitement notamment avec des molécules
et innovante qui risquerait de ne pas
être prises en compte parce qu'il ya des
maladies très très spécifique c'est pour
ça qu'ils aient des était une homélie
natif par rapport aux était une cohorte
donc je suis pas entièrement rassurés
mais par contre je veux bien mallié aux
arguments de catherine des roches qui a
particulièrement travaillé sujet là à
travers les auditions qui ont été faites
et les propositions dans l'amendement du
rapporteur général mais nous resterons
d'une grande vigilance à côté des
associations par rapport à cela parce
que je crois que à travers des mesures
budgétaires parfois on peut avoir des
conséquences contre-productive
donc tous en europe et le retire il est
retiré de 128 955 je dis oui merci
monsieur le président je vais aussi
retiré l'amendement au bénéfice des
amendements déposés par le rapporteur je
veux insister sur cette difficulté que
nous rencontrons le système daté eu est
un système que le monde entier nous à
envier continue encore de nous envier
mais peut-être de moins en moins parce
que il est aujourd'hui réduit dans ses
possibilités par de nombreuses
restrictions faut souligner que les deux
types date ait eu qui sont évoqués
aujourd'hui ne sont pas de même nature
la techno minati concerne un seul malade
allez attribuer par l' agence à la
demande du médecin et quelquefois ce
médicament va lui servir aux patients de
traitement sur une très longue durée
j'ai souligné tout à l'heure que
quelquefois ces médicaments en hâte et
nominative pouvais avoir un prix
manifestement très élevé est exagéré
date et une cohorte est un autre
dispositif qui précède link et
qui entrent plus donc dans la mise à
disposition d innovation en direction
des patients il y as besoin
effectivement d'un débat sur ces
dispositifs
aujourd'hui je vais aussi chers
collègues donc le 128 155 sont retirés
au profit des 23-24 donc je mets aux
voileux 23 de la commission avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient s il est
adopté même vote pour le 24 mai motte
pour le 24 il est adopté également et je
mets aux voix l'article 30 qui est pour
l'article 30 qui est content qui
s'abstient il est adopté l'article 31 de
214 madame cohen
nous proposons par cet amendement de
supprimer cet article qui vise à
transférer le financement de l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé et de l' agence
nationale de santé publique de l'état à
l'assurance maladie
cela représente un coût pour la sécurité
sociale de 270 millions d'euros qui pour
le moment est compensé par l'état
mais ce n'est pas dit qu'il y reste
comme nos collègues gdr à l'assemblée
nationale nous nous permettons tout de
même de nous interroger sur le sens de
cette mesure consiste à transférer le
financement de ces organismes à la
sécurité sociale et nous semble que leur
financement devrait relever du budget de
l'état tout comme leur mission relève de
la puissance publique
en effet l'état continue de jouer un
rôle en matière de prévention et de
santé publique
par ailleurs nous nous inquiétons de la
pérennité de la compensation par l'état
du coût du financement de ces agences
par la sécurité sociale
en effet nous constatons que le principe
de compensation fait l'objet de plus en
plus de dérogations
donc comment exclure quel avenir l'état
ne rembourse plus à la sécurité sociale
les sommes affectées pour la nsm et la
rspt monsieur le rapporteur
nous sommes également sur le président
contre le transfert à
l'assurance-maladie du financement des
ce de santé publique france qui est un
organisme national de veille
épidémiologique et de veille sanitaire
qui nous semble devoir rester évidemment
sous le pilotage de l'état en revanche
le transfert à l'assurance-maladie du
financement de nsn semble plus légitime
puisque l'âge ans occupe une place
centrale dans la politique de sécurité
du médicament et des pratiques médicales
nous proposons donc aux auteurs de
l'amendement de se ranger à l'amendement
25 de la commission qui sera présentée
ensuite c'est donc une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable
merci nana ministre permettez moi
d'émettre un avis sur l'ensemble des
amendements qui porte sur les mêmes
thématiques
nous avons eu le débat hier dans le
cadre de la mission dans le cadre du plf
sur la mission santé j'avais déjà émis
des avis défavorables et peut-être vous
re préciser que le financement est
assuré à titre prennent par le biais de
la tva merci donc il ya une demande de
retrait il est maintenu maicon au
maintien d'autant plus vu la réponse de
la ministre voit l'amendement 214 avec
un double avis défavorable pas dont le
scénario
merci le président madame la ministre il
ya quand même un problème qui se pose
parce que j'espère que l'état donne va
le financement nécessaire à la haine s m
nous sommes avec laurence cohen au
conseil d'administration appui de notre
collègue
enfin bon on est trois le nombre bien
plus eh bien je pense qu'il va y avoir
des problèmes
et finalement c'est un organisme ou sans
doute on peut imaginer que ce soit la
sécurité sociale qu'il paye mais
franchement on avait fait linverse il ya
quelques années il n'y a pas très
longtemps et on revient dans l'autre
sens ça me paraît quand même très très
curieux on a le sentiment même si je
veux pas aller peut-être jusque là mais
chargé le budget de la sécurité sociale
comme ça se passe en ce moment je crois
que ce qui a été dit en début de séance
aujourd'hui
on avait tendance à croire qu'on voulait
mettre absolument le budget de la
sécurité sociale en déficit et bien et
conforter encore un peu plus alors moi
je suis désolé mais je pense pas que ce
soit une très bonne chose de faire ça
merci chers collègues dont je mets au
voile amendement 214 avec un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement
qu'est pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté deux amendements
identiques le 25 et le cac 40 3,25
monsieur rapporteur s'agit de supprimer
deux alinéas de l'article 31 et je crois
que notre collègue de rioz via bien
d'expliquer la raison
le transfert du financement de santé
publique france de l'état vers
l'assurance maladie intervient seulement
trois ans après le que le gouvernement
nous eu précisément fait le choix est
précisément par donc fait le choix
inverse en loi de finances pour 2010
cette tête alors apparu au gouvernement
légitime d'assurer un financement
intégral par l'état de cet opérateur
chargé principalement des missions de
surveillance à comment on l'a rappelé à
l'instar de lance est ce dans un
contexte de multiplication des risques
sanitaires
on l'a vu récemment un lactalis mourenx
notre âme de paris du brise hall qui
mobilise fortement nos agences de
surveillance épidémiologique
cet amendement vise à éviter le
désengagement de l'état dans le
financement de santé publique france et
en a fait un affaiblissement du pilotage
national donc 7
la raison de cet amendement et le 143
identique monsieur dit oui merci
monsieur le président les arguments sont
identiques je ne la prends pas j'aurais
simplement rappelé que ce matin dans la
discussion générale lorsque j'ai insisté
sur ce déficit que j'ai appelé pour ma
part un déficit politique c'est à dire
non pas creuser mais affiché bien
intentionnellement par le gouvernement
j'avais ajouté à différentes mesures de
non le compensation justement le
transfert du financement de ces deux
organismes
merci
donc le gouvernement a déjà donné son
avis mais un ministre a donné un avis
défavorable à la mongolie pour
explications de vote le président même
la ministre de commission denquête en
commission denquête on demande à ce
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de pilotage
national de ce type de de problème donc
moi je vais soutenir évidemment
l'amendement 25 de la commission merci
donc jamais on voit ces deux amendements
identiques 25143 avec de la commission
et de monsieur d'audignies avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés
je mets au mois l'article 31 qui est
pour l'article de 31 kg et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
nous passons à l'article 32 quatre
amendements identiques le premier de 98
madame mélo
merci monsieur le président l'assemblée
nationale a introduit une disposition
visant à mettre en place une démarche
active d'information et d'accompagnement
auprès de bénéficiaires de l'allocation
aux adultes handicapés el harrach à
l'ouverture ou au renouvellement de la
complémentaire santé solidaire néanmoins
la rédaction ne vise pas l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires de la hache aussi cet
amendement vise à couvrir l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires concernés
merci merci le 144 monsieur d'audi oui
merci monsieur le président madame élise
les chats collègues mon groupe politique
mais nous saluons l'introduction par
l'assemblée nationale
la disposition qui vise la formation et
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires de la
hache à l'ouverture et au renouvellement
de la complémentaire santé mais
néanmoins la rédaction ne vise pas
l'ensemble des bénéficiaires est l'objet
de ce amendements à l'instar d'autres
présentés et de couvrir l'ensemble de la
population concernée merci le 200 cars
identique madame dillmann d'antiques en
insistant sur le fait qu' à juste titre
le rapport du gouvernement parlement
remis en 2018 sur le non recours pour la
seule tâche est de nature à nous pousser
à vérifier que tout le monde pourra bien
bénéficier de cette information
merci de 233 monsieur d'avril
défendue identique monsieur le
rapporteur favorable sur position de la
commission car ce que ce amendement
apporte une tarification bienvenue en
précisant que les bénéficiaires de l'aj
deux sont également visés par la mesure
manas ministre aura une demande de
retrait puisque pour nous il est
satisfait dans la science ou la
rédaction de l'article permet bien est
d'ores et déjà d'appliquer cette mesure
à tous les bénéficiaires de la hache et
non uniquement les bénéficiaires de la
hache la formation pro actif sur les
droits la complémentaire santé solidaire
couvre donc bien les déjà les
bénéficiaires de la hache deux c'est à
dire ceux qui ont un taux d'incapacité
compris entre 55 19% et une restriction
une restriction substantielle et durable
pour l'accès à l'emploi
sinon ce sera un avis défavorable merci
donc je me tourne vers les hauteurs ils
sont maintenus mais leur supposée ans
croit qu'il faut le best madame la
ministre je pense qu'il faut le
maintenir pour que voilà la rédaction
soit soit complétée puisque il
semblerait que la rédaction ne vise pas
l'ensemble des bénéficiaires donc il
faut il faut le préciser me semble-t-il
métro voile 81 10 844 215 233 avec un
avis favorable la commission d'avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui est content qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés le 145 monsieur de 10 merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chaque collège nous souhaitons supprimer
la référence à l'âge dans la fixation du
tarif du contrat de la complémentaire
santé solidaire ouvriers novembre 2019
la cmu c est la cs ont fusionné pour
créer la c2 est complémentaire santé
solidaire il est prévu dans cet article
que la participation financière des
bénéficiaires de l'aide complémentaire
santé varie en fonction de l'âge du
bénéficiaire ce qui nous semble
discriminant nous considérons qu'il ya
là une logique assurantielle privé qui a
primé dans les choix et qui conduit à
une politique tarifaire discriminatoire
en fonction de l'âge des bénéficiaires
nous voulons ici rappeler qu'en matière
de protection sociale
le principe qui doit primer qui a déjà
été rappelé que chacun cotise selon ses
moyens et reçoit selon ses besoins
cette logique d'âge qui est en réalité
une logique comptable
ne peut-être la règle et c'est une
ambition que nous portons d'où cet
amendement merci monsieur rapporteur je
comprends le président je comprends
l'amendement de notre collègue yves
daudigny comprend l'objectif social
le critère de l'âge justifié en raison
de la variation de la sinistralité et
des besoins de santé en fonction de
l'âge rappelle que ce contrat sera
proposée par les organismes
complémentaires est de plus l'un des
objectifs est de rendre nouveau contrat
de sortie de la complémentaire santé
solidaire plus attractif pour les jeunes
adultes que les dispositifs existants en
tout état de cause donc le tarif sera
encadrée pour tous
il est souhaitable que ce tarif reste
acceptable pour tous les assurés quel
que soit l'âge on est bien d'accord sur
ce point
je vous propose donc de retirer cet
amendement des faux avis défavorable
merci même avis il est maintenu en
retirer oui monsieur présent il est
maintenu il est maintenue parce qu'il y
a 2 de logique une logique est celle des
mutuelles qui est de jouer la solidarité
entre les entre les générations et des
mutuelles même aujourd'hui dans le
contexte concurrentiel essaie de mettre
en pratique ce principe
et puis à la logique des assurances
privées ou là un cos là le paiement est
lié au risque et donc il est plus faible
pour les jeunes plus important pour les
personnes âgées
c'est une disposition qui nous semble
contraire à une protection sociale
solidaire
donc je maintiens cet amendement adam
lind demande monsieur de digne et très
important parce qu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on cherche à segmenter
les les protections contre les risques
pour pouvoir mettre en concurrence
par segment chacune des opérations et
donc vous priver la mutualité de la
fonction générale de solidarité parce
qu'elles vont être concurrencé sur les
marchés sur les créneaux qui
correspondent aux prestations à moindre
risque et
rentable et puis évidemment elles seront
attendus pour les autres prestations doc
si on veut garder un esprit mutualiste
fort de notre pays et pas basculer vers
l'assurance yale segmenté ce type
d'amendement est une forme de protection
et ne pas l'accepter et serait une forme
de dérive
merci chers collègues dont jeu mais se
voit le sort 45 avec un âne double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée je mets au bois
l'article 32 qui est pour l'article 32
qui est content qui s'abstient il est
adopté à l'article 33 une prise de
parole de même rhéaume cet article
instaurant une prise en charge intégrale
des frais liés à la contraception pour
l'ensemble des mineurs est bien
évidemment le bienvenu
l'utilité d'une mise à disposition
gratuite de moyens de contraception
n'est plus à démontrer le département du
nord et mon arrondissement du
valenciennois plus particulièrement sont
très concernés par les grossesses
précoces
si la prise en charge intégrale des
frais liés à la contraception est une
initiative plus qu'apprécié 1 ne saurait
toutefois se suffire à elle-même
il est impératif que cette mesure soit
doublé d'actions de prévention en santé
sexuelle seront les parfois endossée par
les centres de protection maternelle et
infantile en maternité ou en ville qui
mène des actions de planification
familiale les hôpitaux et maternités
sont généralement des établissements
accessibles en transports en commun qui
facilite par le nom leur localisation
particulière est souvent éloignée des
centre villes
le maintien de l'anonymat favorisant
l'accessibilité des mineurs à leur
service or dans le nord la fermeture de
quatre pmi en maternité a été annoncé
comment assurer la mise en oeuvre d'une
telle politique alors que les lieux de
ressources disparaissent petit à petit
il est ainsi urgent de prendre des
mesures pour assurer le maintien de ses
services médico sociaux car le
remboursement de la contraception
s'avère peu utile c'est les
infrastructures les mettant à
disposition se retrouvent
progressivement fermé merci chers
collègues je mets au voleur
33 qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté l'article 34
l'amendement 146 monsieur d'audi
oui monsieur le président avec votre
autorisation je vais présenter en même
temps les trois amendements donc 146 147
et 148 donc nous mesurerons mes chers
collègues madame un ministre la gravité
du phénomène des pénuries de médicaments
dont nous savons qu'elles touchent à la
fois les pharmacies devise d'officine et
les établissements ces ruptures de stock
sont susceptibles généré des pertes de
chance pour les patients elle créer de
l'anxiété et elle complexifie très
fortement le travail des unités
hospitalières les causes en sont
multiples elles sont réparties tout au
long de la chaîne du médicament qui est
particulièrement complexe des substances
actives jusqu'à la dispensation par les
pharmaciens
il n'existe aucune solution miracle qui
pourrait régler
c'est ce problème donc immédiatement et
je veux saluer alors je dis beaucoup de
mal du gouvernement depuis ce matin je
veux saluer l'engagement du gouvernement
sur ce sujet et je porte l'espoir que le
rapport aux sénatoriales qui a été
rédigé l'an prochain et pu éclairer
cette démarche les propositions
contenues dans cette loi de financement
très social sont solides car elles
concernent directement les laboratoires
sur trois points essentiels la
constitution de stocks obligation
d'achat à l'étranger et les sanctions
ayant travaillé sur ce sujet alors bien
évidemment j'étais parti j'ai participé
au rapport ayant travaillé sur ce sujet
avec les professionnels j'avais préparé
pour la première lecture toute une série
d'amendements dont l'un d'ailleurs
identique au mien a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale ce qui prouve que
ce travail était ou mois pour partie
fondées alors la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositions doit s me semble-t-il la
plus facile possible la plus éclairée et
j'aurais souhaité que madame la ministre
puisse répondre sur les arguments qui
sont présentés par ces amendements
alors pour
le premier c'est